All right, lady, you know that Lee was just shooting his movie in Oklahoma City. And the movie gave him a place to stay because he was there for months. Right. But for two of those weeks, me and the kids came out to join him and the place he was staying in that the movie provided. It was just too small to your whole family. We're a whole family. He went on Airbnb, got us the most beautiful, spacious place to stay. With the nicest host. Well you know if you're planning a trip or you're working
好的，女士，你知道李刚在俄克拉荷马城拍摄他的电影。因为他在那里待了几个月，电影制片方为他提供了住处。没错。但在那几个星期里，我和孩子们去和他团聚，电影方提供的住处对我们全家来说太小了。我们是一大家子人。他上了爱彼迎（Airbnb），为我们找了一个最漂亮、宽敞的住处，房东也特别好。嗯，你知道如果你正在计划旅行或者在某地工作，想住爱彼迎，我觉得你们一定要看看他们的“房客最爱”，因为那是爱彼迎上最受欢迎的房源。哦！我们住的就是“房客最爱”！我们住进了“房客最爱”。你吓到我了。抱歉，这是真的。你太激动了。我是挺激动的。嗯，对，我的意思是，你住的是别人住过的家。是的。
somewhere and you want to stay at an Airbnb, I think you guys got to check out their guest favorite because those are the most loved homes on Airbnb. Oh! We were a guest favorite! We were in a guest favorite. You scared me. So sorry, it's true. You're so excited. I was. Well, yeah, I mean, you're actually getting a home other people have stayed in. Yes.
而且你知道它评价很好。好吧，听着，我们是爱彼迎的忠实粉丝，原因有很多。所以，为你的下一次冒险考虑一下爱彼迎吧。大家好，欢迎收看第二季的第二杯饮品，本集主题是“带女儿上班日”。好吧，女士，我翻看了我们的信箱，一直翻到了这集播客播出时我们建立的文件夹。
And you know it's been well reviewed. Well, listen, we are huge fans of Airbnb for so many reasons. So for your next adventure, consider Airbnb. Hi there, and welcome to your second drink of season two's episode, Take Your Daughter to Work Day. Well, lady, I went back to our mailbag, like all the way back to the folder that we had for when this episode of the podcast aired.
我找了找关于“带女儿上班日”的信件，看看有没有我们还没回复的。太棒了。我的意思是，这可是追溯到2020年的。我喜欢。让我先从一波粉丝来信开始，因为这集播客播出后，
And I looked for any letters about Take Your Daughter to Work Day that maybe we hadn't answered. Great. I mean, this is all the way back to 2020. I love it. And let me start with a fan mail flurry, because after this podcast aired,
我真的很想知道“Jitters”咖啡店是不是真实存在的地方。嗯，凯蒂·N（Katie N）写信说，我正在听“带女儿上班日”那一集。是的，Jitters曾经确实存在。我在内华达州博尔德市长大，在星巴克出现之前，我们就有那家店。在内华达州亨德森的当地社区学院也有一家。不确定他们是否开到了宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿，但我希望这能给
I had really wondered if Jitters, the coffee shop, was a real place. Well, Katie N wrote in and said, I'm listening to the Take Your Daughter to Workday episode. And yes, Jitters used to be a thing. I grew up in Boulder City, Nevada and that is what we had pre-Starbucks. There was also one at the local community college in Henderson, Nevada. Not sure if they ever made it to Scranton, Pennsylvania, but I hope that gives some closure
珍娜那40分钟的徒劳搜寻画上句号。弗朗西斯卡·B（Francesca B）说，在宾夕法尼亚州的匹兹堡有一家Jitters咖啡店。我不知道它是什么时候开的，但咖啡很棒，而且非常可爱。我们还收到了一封来自“我不是你叔叔史蒂夫”（I Am Not Your Uncle Steve）的信，他说，Jitters是蒸汽城购物中心（Steamtown Mall）里真实存在的地方。它就在美食广场的角落，后来变成了一家糖果店。哦，原来它在商场里。我想是的。
to Jenna's 40-minute hunt for nothing. And Francesca B. said, there is a Jitters coffee shop in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. I don't know when it was established, but the coffee is great and it's very cute. We also got a letter from I Am Not Your Uncle Steve, who said, Jitters was a real place in the Steamtown Mall. It was on the corner of the food court and eventually became a candy store. Oh, so it was in the mall. I guess it was.
最后，雷恩沙特尔女士（Ms. Rainshuttle）说，我朋友丈夫的家人曾经拥有过Jitters。天哪，你找到了当事人。但商场拒绝续租，并用星巴克取代了它。哦。但我必须说声谢谢，因为当我重温我们对这一集的分析时，我回想起我花了很长时间试图查明Jitters是否真实存在，我很感激能知道答案。
And then finally, Ms. Rainshuttle said, My friend's husband's family used to own Jitters. Oh my gosh, you found the people. But the mall refused to renew their lease and replaced it with a Starbucks. Oh. But I have to just say thank you everyone because when I was revisiting our breakdown of this, I was reminded that I spent a very long time trying to find out if Jitters was a real place and I appreciate knowing.
是的。好吧，你们还为这一集发来了一些有趣的背景捕捉。我喜欢背景捕捉。特蕾莎·W（Teresa W）发的这个太棒了。是的。好吧，你们还为这一集发来了一些有趣的背景捕捉。我喜欢背景捕捉。特蕾莎·W发的这个太棒了。好吧，听着，你可能记得我们一直在追踪安吉拉和罗伊，我们一直在寻找他们恋情的迹象。我也很喜欢特蕾莎开始她信件的方式。准备好了吗？
Yeah. Well, you guys also sent in some fun background catches for this episode. I love a background catch. This one from Teresa W is fantastic. Yeah. Well, you guys also sent in some fun background catches for this episode. I love a background catch. This one from Teresa W. is fantastic. Okay, so listen, you might remember that we had been tracking Angela and Roy, and we had been looking for signs of their romance. And I also loved how Teresa started her letter. Ready?
好的。她写道，好的，好的，好的，准备好让你的大脑爆炸吧。八个感叹号。你们在追踪安吉拉和罗伊。在“带女儿上班日”这一集大约15分钟时，当罗伊和梅雷迪思的孩子摔跤时，镜头拉远到吉姆，背景里是安吉拉看着罗伊摔跤并微笑着。我想安吉拉看到了罗伊有多强壮，并对他感到满意。我想她也看到了他可以有多风趣，而安吉拉有点被这一点吸引。
Okay. She wrote, okay, okay, okay, Get ready for your mind to be blown. Eight exclamation points. You guys are tracking Angela and Roy. At around 15 minutes of the Bring Your Daughter to Work Day episode, when Roy is wrestling with Meredith's kid, it zooms out to Jim and in the background is Angela watching Roy wrestle and smiling. I think that Angela sees how strong Roy is and is pleased with him. I think she also sees how fun he can be and Angela is kind of attracted to that.
我的意思是，我毫不怀疑安吉拉看着罗伊摔跤、表现得像个父亲一样时感到很高兴。我觉得她对他有意思。你知道，安吉拉在剧中的情人比其他任何人都多吗？我不知道。我前几天还在想这个问题，因为她对帕姆那么爱评头论足。帕姆，办公室的“床垫”？正是。但事实是，她和很多人约会过，而且很多人都是办公室里的。这是真的。确实是真的。
I mean, I have no doubt that Angela was delighted watching Roy wrestle, be kind of a dad figure. I think she was into him. You know, did Angela have more lovers on the show than anyone else? I don't know. I was thinking about this the other day because she is so judgmental of Pam. Pam, the office mattress? Exactly. But the truth is, she dated a lot of folks and a lot of folks in the office. It's true. It is true.
安迪和德怀特，还有参议员。是的。我漏掉谁了吗？我觉得我漏掉了一个人。参议员不在办公室里。不，确实。但我不知道。好吧，她确实说过她曾有不止一组男人为她决斗。是的，正是。另一个背景捕捉来自巴斯玛·K（Basma K）。巴斯玛说，
Andy and Dwight, but also the senator. Yes. Am I missing someone? I feel like there's someone I'm missing. The senator wasn't in the office. No, true. But I don't know. Well, she did say that she's had more than one set of men duel over her. Yes, exactly. Another background catch comes from Basma K. Basma says,
托比在11分26秒时在背景里做了一些有趣的事，然后在11分30秒又做了一次。他在厨房里，在百叶窗后面，静静地看着迈克尔带孩子们参观办公室，这时克里德开始脱鞋。我觉得保罗在那一幕里太搞笑了。你知道，重温这部剧时我最喜欢的事情之一就是观察像这样的小背景时刻。因为我们总是用我们对事物的反应来填补那一刻。你第一次看的时候真的无法全部看到。
Toby does something interesting in the background at 11 minutes and 26 seconds, and then again at 11 minutes and 30 seconds. He's in the kitchen, behind the window blinds, quietly watching Michael give a tour of the office to the kids as Creed begins to take off his shoes. I just thought Paul was hilarious in that scene. You know, one of my favorite things about rewatching the show is watching little background moments like this. Because we were always just filling the moment with our reactions to things. And you really can't see them all the first time you watch.
所以我喜欢这个。谢谢你指出这一点。这真的非常非常有趣。好吧，我注意到我们没有多谈这一集的删减片段，其中很多已经被加回了孔雀（Peacock）的超级粉丝版剧集中。我最喜欢的是一个新的冷开场会议室场景。安吉拉，你正在尝试为“带女儿上班日”设定菜单。你一定要听听。我想五个原味和一个素食的应该够了。现在来点意大利辣香肠怎么样？我喜欢多加芝士。
So I loved this. Thank you for pointing this out. This was very, very fun. Well, I noticed that we didn't talk much about the deleted scenes in this episode, and a lot of them have been added back to the Peacock superfan episode. My favorite is a new cold open conference room scene. Angela, you are trying to set the menu for Take Your Daughter to Work Day. You have to hear it. I think five plain and one veggie should be fine. How about pepperoni now? I like extra cheese.
绝对不行。我也喜欢多加芝士。不。我喜欢多加芝士。绝对不行。我也喜欢多加芝士。好吧。我们要教给孩子们的第一课将是关于肥胖。然后你听不太清，
Absolutely not. I like extra cheese too. No. I like extra cheese. Absolutely not. I like extra cheese too. Fine. The first lesson we'll teach the children will be about obesity. And then you can't really hear it,
但在他低声说，BJS瑞安说，谢谢。因为他会得到他想要的披萨。我想指出的另外两个删减片段，它们其实真的很让人心碎。第一个是由洛根·T（Logan T）指出的。他说，我不知道你有没有注意到，但在“男孩和女孩”那一集中，帕姆画了一幅画，你可以在14分54秒看到。然后它后来出现在“带女儿上班日”的一个删减片段中，当时凯文女朋友的女儿看到了
but under his breath, BJS Ryan goes, thank you. Cause he's gonna get the pizza he wanted. The other two deleted moments that I wanted to flag, they're real heartbreakers actually. The first one was pointed out by Logan T. Who said, I don't know if you noticed this or not, but in Boys and Girls, Pam is drawing a picture that you can see at 14 minutes and 54 seconds. And then it comes up later in a deleted scene of Take Your Daughter to Work Day when Kevin's girlfriend's daughter sees that
那张画在帕姆的桌子上。是的，嗯，凯文未婚妻的女儿艾比（Abby）是由格雷格的女儿海莉（Hayley）扮演的。是的！所以在这集里，帕姆拼命想和孩子建立联系，有一次，艾比走到她的桌子前拿糖果，当艾比注意到这幅画时，艾比和帕姆有了这段小小的交流。
same picture on Pam's desk. Yes., well Kevin's fiance's daughter, Abby, is played by Greg's daughter, Hayley. Yes! So in this episode, Pam is desperately trying to bond with a kid, and at one point, Abby comes up to her desk to get some candy, and Abby and Pam have this little exchange when Abby notices this drawing.
让我们听听。是你画的吗？是的。你喜欢画画吗，艾比？是的，我长大后想成为一名艺术家。我也是。你已经是大人了。你已经是大人了。
Let's listen. Did you draw that? Yeah. Do you like to draw, Abby? Yeah, I wanna be an artist when I grow up. Me too. You are a grownup. You are a grownup.
我知道。这是出自孩子之口的真理。是的，是的。然后在这一集的结尾还有一个标签，在超级粉丝版中是新的。它显示迈克尔继续观看儿童节目的录像。记得早些时候我们看到儿童节目的一部分，瑞安不得不去他妈妈家拿磁带。
I know. This is the truth out of like the mouth of babes. Yes, yes. And then there was also a tag at the end of the episode that is new in the superfan episode. It shows Michael continuing to watch the footage from the children's show. Remember earlier we see part of the children's show that Ryan had to go to his mom's house to get the tape.
但在最初播出的那一集中，我们看到的唯一部分是小迈克尔表现得非常尴尬，他说他想有100个孩子，这样他就能有100个朋友，这样就没人能拒绝做他的朋友。但在结尾的录像中，小迈克尔被看到为其他孩子表演魔术，他让他们笑了。
But the only part we see in the episode, as it originally aired, was the part where little Michael is being very awkward and he's saying he wants to have 100 kids so he can have 100 friends so no one can say no to being his friend. But in the footage at the end, little Michael is seen performing magic for the other kids and he's making them laugh.
最后，一个小女孩走过来在他耳边低语，他笑了，好像她在和他调情。这太感人了。这是我真心希望保留在原剧集中的一个片段。这是一个如此温柔的时刻。再次重申，我喜欢戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）精心制作的这些新小片段。是的。
And then at the end, a little girl comes up and whispers in his ear and he smiles like she's maybe flirting with him. It is so touching. And this is one that I really wish lived in the original episode. It is such a tender moment. And just again some of the things I'm loving in these new little nuggets that Dave Rogers is so carefully crafting. Yes.
最后，我只想对我的卢比餐厅（Luby's）同好们说声谢谢。你知道卢比餐厅，我以前常和祖父母去的自助餐厅。哦，你在这一集里谈了很多关于它的事。我知道，我知道。嗯，来自德克萨斯州威奇托福尔斯的泰勒·M（Tyler M）。威奇托福尔斯怎么了？我的意思是，你知道我了解威奇托福尔斯吗？我的意思是，你知道，我了解威奇托福尔斯。我的意思是，我们经常去那里。
Finally, I just wanted to say thank you to my fellow Luby's lovers out there. You know Luby's, the cafeteria I would go to with my grandparents. Oh, you talk all about it in this episode. I know, I know. Well Tyler M. from Wichita Falls, Texas. What's up Wichita Falls? I mean, you know I know Wichita Falls? I mean, you know, I know Wichita Falls. I mean, we went there all the time.
泰勒说，我的曾祖父母每次我和他们在一起时都会带我去卢比餐厅。泰勒，我敢打赌我们当时在同一个地方。可能吧。泰勒说，听到安吉拉对它赞不绝口，我的心都暖了。听到她甚至只是提到德克索马（Texoma），我就超级兴奋。接下来你知道吗，她提到了我的家乡。戴安娜·K（Diana K）说，
Tyler says, my great grandparents always took me to Luby's any time I was with them. Tyler, I bet we were there at the same time. Probably. Tyler says, my heart was warmed hearing Angela rave about it. I got super ecstatic hearing her even just mention Texoma. And next thing you know, she mentioned my hometown. And Diana K said,
在圣安东尼奥长大，我经常和祖父母在那里吃饭。这显然是祖父母的首选。我们会在周日下午礼拜后在同一个地点和他们见面，那是我一周中最精彩的时刻。我喜欢拿到自己的托盘，挑选任何我想要的东西，包括甜点，感觉自己长大了。现在当我回去时，我尽量至少去吃一次。呜呼，德州女孩团结起来！我喜欢这些。好吧，听着，谢谢大家的收听，请享受我们对“带女儿上班日”的分析。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。
growing up in San Antonio, I ate there all the time with my grandparents. It was clearly a grandparents go-to. We would meet them there at the same location on Sunday afternoons following church and it was the highlight of my week. I loved getting my own tray and picking out whatever I wanted, including dessert and feeling so grown up. Now when I visit, I try to eat at one at least once. Woohoo, Texas girls unite! I love those. Well, listen, thanks everyone for listening and please enjoy our breakdown of Take Your Daughter to Work Day. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会分析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嘿。你好。
We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hey. Hello.
如果你有女儿，你今天可以带她去上班。是的。今天是“带女儿上班日”。去邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）。第二季，第18集。这一集由敏迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）编剧，维克多·内利二世（Victor Nellie Jr.）导演。维克多·内利。
If you have a daughter, you can take her to work today. Yes. It's Take Your Daughter to Work Day. To Dunder Mifflin. Season 2, episode 18. This one's written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Victor Nellie Jr. Victor Nellie.
他导演的第二部。是的，多产的电视导演。他太棒了。我们真的很喜欢他。他太好了。我应该从总结开始吗？珍娜，你知道那是你开始的方式。我知道。
Second one he's directed. Yes, prolific TV director. He's fantastic. We really liked him. He was so nice. Should I start with a summary? Jenna, you know that's how you start. I know.
做就是了。我应该按顺序做。但我喜欢你每周都问我。每周你都说，我应该从总结开始吗？如果我说，不，今天不行，女士。我会怎么做？我不知道。你会听我的，还是会不管怎样都做？
Just do it. I should just do it in order. I like every week though that you ask me. Every week you're like, should I start with a summary? Like what if I was like, no, not today, lady. What would I do? I don't know. Would I listen to you or would I just do it anyway?
你可能会像车灯前的鹿一样。你知道吗？试着某一周这样做，我们看看。好的，我会的。但不是这周。你让我做的。做吧。我来了。在这一集中，邓德·米夫林的员工
You'd probably be during headlights. You know what? Try it some week and we'll see. Okay, I will. But not this week. You told me to do it. Do it.. You'd probably be during headlights. You know what? Try it some week and we'll see. OK, I will. But not this week. You told me to do it. Do it. Here I go. In this episode, the Dunder Mifflin employees
带他们的女儿来上班。斯坦利带了他十几岁的女儿，她开始迷恋瑞安。我的意思是，她只是敏迪的一个版本，对吧？有一点。有一点。瑞安有什么魅力？女士们喜欢瑞安。
bring their daughters to work for the day. Stanley brings his teenage daughter, who starts crushing on Ryan. I mean, she's just a version of Mindy, right? A little bit. A little bit. What is it about Ryan? The ladies love Ryan.
我知道。凯文带了他未婚妻的女儿。对。梅雷迪思带了她的儿子，托比带了他有点害羞的五岁女儿，她最终和迈克尔建立了联系。在这一集中，帕姆的任务是和一个孩子交朋友。就一个。是的，我们了解到帕姆不擅长应付孩子。
I know. Kevin brings his fiance's daughter. Right. Meredith brings her son and Toby brings his kind of shy five-year-old daughter who ends up bonding with Michael. Also in this episode, Pam makes it her mission to befriend just one kid. Just one. Yeah, we learned that Pam is not good with kids.
显然不是。好吧，我们应该做我们的快问快答吗？你为什么要问我？因为那是其中的一部分。是的，做吧。做快问快答的一部分就是我问你是否应该做快问快答。是的，特里娜，你应该做你的快问快答。
Apparently not. All right, should we do our fast facts? Why are you asking me? Because that's part of it. Yes, do them. Part of doing the fast facts is me asking you if I should do the fast facts. Yes, Trina, you should do your fast facts.
快问快答第一条，我们收到了很多关于这一集中孩子的问题。所以让我们一个一个地分析。斯坦利的女儿梅丽莎（Melissa）由爵士·雷·科尔（Jazz Rae Cole）扮演。好的。她是一位专业演员。和剧中的任何人都没有关系。我们雇了她。
Fast fact number one, we got a lot of questions about the kids in this episode. So let's break them down one by one. Stanley's daughter, Melissa, was played by Jazz Rae Cole. Okay. And she is a professional actress. No relation to anyone on the show. We hired her.
她也出演了情景喜剧《我的老婆和孩子》（My Wife and Kids）。当她拍摄这一集时，她17或18岁。所以她的生日在二月。我想那正是我们拍摄的时候。我记得她告诉我她刚满18岁。当我第一次来到洛杉矶时，我二十多岁，但我看起来像个十几岁的人。
She was also on the sitcom, My Wife and Kids. When she shot this episode, she was 17 or 18 years old. So her birthday is in February. And I think that's right around the time we were shooting. And I have this memory of her telling me that she had just turned 18. When I first came to Los Angeles, I was in my twenties, but I looked like I was a teenager.
对。所以我有一个特别的经纪人，会派我去试镜扮演高中生的角色。因为当你在片场有孩子时，他们的工作时间非常有限。根据工会规则，他们有儿童工作时间。所以他们不能工作那么长时间。他们必须休息。必须有一位导师教他们学校的东西。所以如果你
Right. And so I had this special agent who would send me out for roles to play high school kids. Because when you have a kid on a set, they have very limited work hours. They have child hours, according to the union rules. And so they can't work as long of days. They have to take these breaks. There has to be a tutor who teaches them school stuff. So if you
看起来超过18岁，但你能扮演孩子，这就像一个小众市场。我出演了《飞越比弗利》（90210）。天哪，安吉拉。不，你没有。我出演了《飞越比弗利》，我没有台词。但我最大的时刻是我扮演托里·斯佩林（Tori Spelling）的姐妹会成员。我们正在收集选票。我想他们要投票把某个女孩赶出姐妹会。我收集了选票，我必须把它们交给托里。哇。
look older than 18, but you can play a kid, this is like a little niche market. I was in 90210. Oh my gosh, Angela. No, you were not. I was in 90210 and I didn't have lines. My biggest moment though was when I played Tori Spelling's Sororityhuh. And we were collecting votes. I think they were going to vote some girl out of the sorority. And I collected the votes, and I had to hand them to Tori. Whoa.
是的。所以我记得。我记得如果能得到那样的角色感觉很酷，因为你可以工作更长时间，而且你年纪大却扮演年轻角色。我有幸出演了电影《欢乐谷》（Pleasantville），和托比·马奎尔（Toby Maguire）以及瑞茜·威瑟斯彭（Reese Witherspoon）一起。那是个好片子。嗯哼。
Yes. So I remember. I remember it like it was kind of cool if you could get parts like that because you could work longer hours and you were older playing younger. I got to be in the movie Pleasantville with Toby Maguire and Reese Witherspoon. That's a good one. Uh huh.
我工作了一整周，这真的很令人兴奋。我只是一个特约群演。我也是。当我扮演姐妹会成员时，我是特约群演。是的。我在《欢乐谷》里是特约群演，因为我超过18岁却扮演未成年人。是的。天哪。
And I got to work a whole week, which was really exciting. I was just a featured extra. Me too. When I was the sorority sister, I was the featured extra. Yes. I was a featured extra in Pleasantville because I was over 18 to play under. Yeah. Oh my gosh.
我喜欢这个。托比的女儿萨莎（Sasha）由德莱尼·露丝·法瑞尔（Delaney Ruth Farrell）扮演。现在关于她有一个有趣的小花絮。她是我们的布景师肖恩·法瑞尔（Sean Farrell）的女儿。所以你可能记得，我们很久以前有一个托比办公桌的定场镜头，他解释说他离婚了，有一个女儿。有一张小金发女孩的照片。
I love that. Toby's daughter, Sasha, was played by Delaney Ruth Farrell. Now here's a little interesting tidbit about her. She was the daughter of our set dresser, Sean Farrell. So you maybe remember, we had an establishing shot of Toby's desk a while ago, where he explains that he's divorced and he has a daughter. And there is a picture of a little blonde girl.
他说，这是萨莎。那张照片是肖恩放上去的，是他女儿的照片。所以当需要拍这一集时，我们不得不使用她。等等，所以肖恩只是促成了这件事？是的。肖恩只是把她女儿的照片放在了托比的桌子上。嗯，她很可爱。
He says, this is Sasha. That picture was placed there by Sean of his daughter. So when it came time to do this episode, we kind of had to use her. Wait, so did Sean just sort of make that happen? Yeah. Sean just put a picture of his daughter on Toby's desk. Well, she's very cute.
太可爱了，而且她表现得很好。她做得很好。不是演员，只是布景师的女儿。是的，她还会再回来参加“家庭肖像日”。好的，现在是梅雷迪思的儿子。梅雷迪思的儿子很难说。梅雷迪思的儿子。
So cute, and she was so good. She did great. Not an actress, just daughter of our set dresser. Yeah, and she's going to come back again in Family Portrait Day. OK, so now Meredith's son. Meredith's son is hard to say. Meredith's son.
你们，珍娜试了三次。我试过了。梅雷迪思的儿子，杰克·帕尔默（Jake Palmer），由斯宾塞·丹尼尔斯（Spencer Daniels）扮演。和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）没有关系。不。维基百科，你错了。好的。你听到我们了吗？
You guys, Jenna has tried it three times. I have. Meredith's son, Jake guys, Jenna has tried it three times. I have. Meredith's son, Jake Palmer, was played by Spencer Daniels. No relation to Greg Daniels. Nope. Wikipedia, you're wrong. Okay. Did you hear us?
修正它。好的。也许那是别的地方。我读到过。邓德百科（Dunderpedia）。也许是邓德百科。其中一个百科说斯宾塞·丹尼尔斯是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的儿子。他不是。
Fix it. Okay. Maybe that was somewhere else. I read that. Dunderpedia. Maybe it was Dunderpedia. One of the pedias is saying that Spencer Daniels is Greg Daniels' son. He is not.
不是那回事。现在斯宾塞也会在第八季第24集“家庭肖像日”中回来。粉丝问题来自卷发泰丝（Curly Haired Tess）、汉娜·伯塞尔（Hannah Bercel）、丽莎·法尔（Lisa Farr）和许多其他人，梅雷迪思的儿子在第九季安吉拉的单身派对上回来扮演脱衣舞男时，是同一个演员吗？我们会讲到那里的，但那是我一生中最不舒服的
Not the case. Now Spencer is also going to come back in season 8, episode 24, Family Portrait Day. Fan question from Curly Haired Tess and Hannah Bercel and Lisa Farr and many others, was Meredith's son played by the same actor when he came back as the stripper for Angela's bachelorette party in season nine? We'll get there, but that's one of the most uncomfortable
时刻之一。是的，是同一个演员。是的。哦，哦，啊。是的。是的。同一个人。他今天还在演戏。所以他是一位专业演员。那不是针对他个人。只是他当时是个小男孩。我们见到他时他还是个男孩。然后当他成为在你的虚构单身派对上跳脱衣舞的男人时。最后，还有凯文未婚妻的女儿艾比，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯的女儿海莉·丹尼尔斯（Haley Daniels）扮演。是的，海莉非常非常甜。
moments of my life. Yes, it's the same actor. Yes. Oh, oh, ah. Yes. Yes. Same guy. And he's still acting today. So he is a professional actor. That wasn't for him as a person. It was just that he's just a young boy. We met him when he was a boy. And then when he was a man who stripped at your fictional bachelorette party. And then finally, there was Kevin's fiance's daughter, Abby, who was played by Haley Daniels, who is Gray Daniels' daughter. Yes, Haley is so, so sweet.
是的。她做得很好。太棒了。她不是演员。不是演员。她做得太好了。她必须表现得非常冷漠，我觉得她太搞笑了。快问快答第二条。
Yeah. And she did a great job. So good. She's not an actor. Not an actor. She did such a great job. She had to be very deadpan, and I thought she was hilarious. Fast fact number two.
很多人问，和这么多孩子一起拍一集是什么感觉？现在，你还记得什么，安吉？嗯，我的意思是，海莉在我们的会计小角落里待了不少时间，我只是想确保她没事。是的。我想我只是想确保她像，你需要去洗手间吗？
A lot of people ask, what was it like to do an episode with all these kids around? Now, what did you remember about that, Ange? Well, I mean, Haley was in our little accounting nook quite a bit, and I just wanted to make sure she was good. Yeah. I think I just want to make sure she was like, do you need to go to the bathroom?
你有零食吗？我只是变成了那样的人。是的。但显然，当孩子在成人的工作环境中时，你确实会改变你的行为，或者你应该改变。抱歉。我记得我们为此受到了一点说教。是的，哦。
Do you have snacks? I just sort of became that person. Yeah. But obviously, when kids are in an adult work environment, you do change your behavior, or you should. Sorry. I remember we got a little lecture about it. Yeah, oh.
我们确实被谈话了。我们确实被谈话了，实际上。在拍摄开始时。是的，在拍摄开始时。就像，嘿伙计们，片场会有孩子。今天让我们注意一下礼貌。实际上当迈克尔和你在那场冷开场戏里，你说，
We got a little talking to. We got a little talking to, actually. At the beginning of filming. Yeah, at the beginning of filming. Just like, hey guys, there's gonna be kids on set. Let's just mind our manners today. And actually when Michael and you have that scene in the cold open where you're like,
迈克尔，我和你谈过这个。那实际上让我想起了每当我们有客人参观片场时。是的。每当，有时家庭会参观片场。他们会赢得某种参观机会，然后全家都会来。很多时候我们的副导演凯利·坎特利（Kelly Cantley）会说，
Michael, I talked to you about this. That actually reminded me of whenever we had people visiting the set. Yeah. Whenever, sometimes families would visit the set. They would win like some type of visit and a whole family would come. And a lot of times our AD, Kelly Cantley would be like,
嘿，大家注意，有小孩。保持G级（大众级）。并不是说我们是一群粗俗的人，但是，你知道，这就像一群成年人整天在一起。我觉得当没有孩子在场时，确实有不少脏话。确实有。是的，你知道。所以有成人词汇，有成人词汇。但除此之外，我们并没有。是的。超级奇怪或不恰当什么的。
hey, everyone heads up, young children. Keep it G rated. Not that we were like a body group, but, you know, it's like a group of adults all day. I feel like when there weren't kids around, though, there was quite a bit of cursing. There were. Yes, that's you know. So there were adult words that there were adult words. But besides that, we weren't. Yeah. Super like weird or inappropriate or anything.
不，但我们的剧本有一半时间是那样的。那是真的。有一半时间剧本里说的话让我觉得，哦。是的，那是真的。好的。好吧，快问快答第三条。这是粉丝发来的。我喜欢这个。非常感谢，凯利·努多（Kelly Nudo）。她提醒我，Fundle Bundle，你知道，迈克尔小时候参加的那个小电视节目，它是受斯克兰顿一个真实的当地儿童节目“哈奇马拉奇之地”（The Land of Hatchimalatchee）的启发。哦，天哪。我喜欢这个。是的，这是一个从50年代开始的儿童小节目。
No, but our scripts were half the time. That's true. Half the time there were things that were said within the context of a script where I'm like, oh. Yeah, that's true. Okay. All right, fast fact number three. This was sent in by a fan. I loved this. Thank you so much, Kelly Nudo. in by a fan. I loved this. Thank you so much, Kelly Nudo. She tipped me off to the fact that Fundle Bundle, you know, the little TV program that Michael was on as a child in this episode, it was inspired by a real local children's program in Scranton called The Land of Hatchimalatchee. Oh my Lord. I love that. Yes, it was a little program for kids that started in the 50s.
它播出了近25年。当地的。斯克兰顿当地的。是的，它有歌曲和孩子们的出镜，就像我们的版本一样。它最初由一位名叫南希·伯格（Nancy Berg）的女士主持，被称为南希小姐。然后由朱迪小姐主持，
It ran for almost 25 years. Local. Local Scranton. Yes, it featured songs and appearances by kids, just like our version. It was originally hosted by a woman named Nancy Berg, who was referred to as Miss Nancy. And then it was hosted by Miss Judy,
由洛伊斯·伯恩斯（Lois Burns）扮演。我不知道为什么他们叫她朱迪小姐，而她的名字是洛伊斯，但他们确实这么做了。当然，在我们的版本中，我们有特鲁迪小姐，由女演员苏·尼尔森（Sue Nelson）扮演。还有爱德华·R·喵（Edward R. Meow）。是的。
who was played by Lois Burns. I don't know why they called her Miss Judy when her name was Lois, but they did. And of course, in our version, we had Miss Trudy, who was played by actress Sue Nelson. And Edward R. Meow. Yes.
但这真的很甜。扮演朱迪小姐的洛伊斯最近接受了采访，谈到了她在“哈奇马拉奇之地”的时光。我只是喜欢哈奇马拉奇。哈奇马拉奇。哈奇马拉奇。抱歉。它只是让我发笑。
But this was really sweet. Lois, who played Miss Judy, was interviewed recently about her time on the land of Hatchi Malachi. I just love Hatchi Malachi. Hatchi Malachi. Hatchi Malachi. Sorry. It just makes me laugh.
我知道。好的。她关于“哈奇马拉奇之地”说了什么？她说他们的目标是确保每个孩子都知道他们很重要。我喜欢这个。我喜欢那个小花絮。谢谢凯利写信进来，因为那就像，我甚至不知道我们怎么能找到那个。不，那太棒了。那不在我通常用于研究的任何网站上。为了深入挖掘？是的。所以谢谢。她在Office Ladies Pod，在我们的Ins上。她给我发了条消息。
I know. Okay. What did she say about the land of Hatchi Malachi? She said that their goal was to make sure that every kid knew they were important. I love that. I love that little tidbit. Thank you, Kelly, for writing in because that is like, I don't even know how we would find that. No, that's so great. That's not on any of the websites that I usually go to for research. For the deep dive? Yeah. So thank you. She's over on Office Ladies Pod, over on our Insta. She sent me a message.
哦，那太酷了。谢谢。好吧，那些是非常好的快问快答，女士。击掌。哦，和我击掌。那是珍娜和我击掌。是的。有点尴尬
Oh, that's so cool. Thanks. All right, those were some really good fast facts, lady. High five. Oh, high five me. That was Jenna and I high fiving. It was. It's kind of awkward
因为我们必须跨过桌子并使用你的麦克风。我总是担心你的卡片。别弄乱我的卡片，女士。好吧，让我们休息一下，回来进入这一集。是的。想象一下，如果你可以问某人关于他们财务的任何问题。你赚多少钱？谁付了那顿昂贵的晚餐？你的房子到底花了多少钱？在每一集“我们花什么”（What We Spend）中，不同的嘉宾打开他们的钱包，
because we have to reach across the table and use your microphone. And I always worry about your cards. Don't mess up my cards, lady. All right, let's take a break and come back and get into this episode. Yeah. Imagine if you could ask someone anything you wanted about their finances. How much do you make? Who paid for that fancy dinner? What did your house actually cost? On every episode of What We Spend, a different guest opens up their wallets,
打开他们的生活，真的，并告诉我们关于他们财务的一切。有一周，他们告诉我们他们把钱花在什么地方。我儿子在五分钟内就花了6美元买蓝莓。这是一个关于钱如何进入我们的生活然后又离开的播客，当然我们对此都有很多感受。我真的很想要这些东西。我想拥有一所房子。我想有一个孩子。
opens up their lives, really, and tells us all about their finances. For one week, they tell us everything they spend their money on. My son slammed like $6 for the blueberries in five minutes. This is a podcast about all the ways money comes into our lives and then leaves again, which of course we all have a lot of feelings about. I really want these things. I want to own a house. I want to have a child.
但今天早上我真的很想喝咖啡。因为无论你是在购买、不购买、储蓄还是消费，归根结底，钱总是不仅仅是你的余额。我是考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell），这是“我们花什么”。收听并关注“我们花什么”，一个奥德赛（Odyssey）原创播客，现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。好吧，我们回来了。
But this morning I really wanted a coffee. Because whatever you are buying or not buying or saving or spending, at the end of the day, money is always about more than your balance. I'm Courtney Harrell and this is What We Spend. Listen to and follow What We Spend, an Odyssey original podcast, available now wherever you get your podcasts. All right, we're back.
让我们开始分析这一集。我们以帕姆的谈话头开始。是的，她解释说是“带女儿上班日”。她说，我其实不太擅长应付孩子，但我想变得更好，因为我要结婚了。所以她要在桌子上放很多额外的糖果。很多糖果。她还放了一盆盆栽。你看到了吗？那就像是最后一分钟的商店装饰。突然间就有一盆植物。
Let's start breaking down this episode. We open with a Pam talking head. Yeah, she explains that it's take your daughter to work day. And she says, I'm not actually great with kids, but I want to get better because I'm getting married. So she's going to put out lots of extra candy on her desk. Lots of candy. She got like a potted plant. Did you see that? That was like a last minute store graph. There's like all of a sudden a plant.
不，我没注意到。我对我的背景伙伴们有点小关注。好吧。在9秒时，定格，你会看到你的肩膀上方，在会计那边。好的。山姆大叔。
No, I did not notice that. I have a little thing for my background pals. All right. At nine seconds, freeze frame, you're gonna see over your shoulder, it's on the accounting side. Okay. The Uncle Sam.
你记得那个山姆大叔吗？哦，是的，为什么我们有那个家伙？那是一个山姆大叔的玩偶。是的。他戴着独立日帽子，拿着一面旗子。你可以按一个按钮，我想他会播放《扬基歌》（Yankee Doodle Dandy）之类的。
Do you remember the Uncle Sam? Oh yeah, why did we have that guy? It was a doll of Uncle Sam. Yeah. He had the 4th of July hat on, he had a flag. You could hit a button, and I think he would play Yankee Doodle Dandy or something.
Raa, da, ma。我不知道。它就坐在那里。他是什么时候出现的？从一开始？我想他从一开始就在那里。我的意思是，我有关于他的记忆，因为我会转过身去和你说话。
Raa, da, ma. I don't know. It sat there. When did he show up? From the beginning? I think he's there from the beginning. I mean, I have a memory of him cause like I would turn around to go and talk to you.
他是我第一个经过的东西。所以第一次我转过身时，我想，哦天哪，山姆大叔的历史是美国联邦政府常见的国家拟人化。根据传说，它在1812年战争期间开始使用，据说是以塞缪尔·威尔逊（Samuel Wilson）的名字命名的。塞缪尔·威尔逊是谁？
He's what I would pass first. So the first time I turned around, I was like, oh God, history of Uncle Sam is a common national personification of the US federal government. According to legend, it came into use during the war of 1812 and was supposedly named for Samuel Wilson. Who was Samuel Wilson?
嗯，我会点击他。我会告诉你。你在哪里读这个？这是维基百科吗？维基百科。塞缪尔·威尔逊是来自纽约特洛伊的肉类包装商，他的名字据说是美国拟人化山姆大叔的来源。
Well, I'll click on him. I'll tell you. Where are you reading this? Is this Wikipedia? Wikipedia. Samuel Wilson was a meat packer from Troy, New York, whose name is purportedly the source of the personification of the United States Uncle Sam.
看起来有点像——它在绕圈子。它在绕圈子。它在绕圈子。我需要更多地了解肉类包装商山姆。肉类包装商山姆。总之，那是山姆大叔。他在我肩膀上坐了九年。
Kind of looks like a- It's going in a circle. It is going in a circle. It's going in a circle. I need to know more about meatpacker Sam. Meatpacker Sam. Anyway, that's Uncle Sam. He sat over my shoulder for nine years.
我想播客结束后我会花更多时间研究那个。所以如果你想要更多山姆大叔的事实，我可能会把它们带到我们的糖果袋里。好的，带到糖果袋里。所以我为细节控们注意到了一些事情。在21秒时，帕姆桌上的糖果是棒棒糖和救生圈糖。棒棒糖之类的。是的，它基本保持那样。
I think I'm gonna spend more time on that after the podcast is over. So if you want more Uncle Sam facts, I might bring them to our candy bag. Okay, bring them to the candy bag. So I noticed something for kind of the detail folks. At 21 seconds, the candy on Pam's desk is suckers and lifesavers. Lollipop things. Yeah, it pretty much stays that way.
然而，在之前的镜头中，在10秒时，有一碗柠檬糖，一碗星爆（Starburst），还有一个装满软糖的糖果盘。然后那些不见了，然后是棒棒糖。是的。糖果连续性！糖果连续性。发生了什么？
However, in the previous shot at 10 seconds, there's a bowl of lemon drops, a bowl of Starburst, and a candy dish full of jelly beans. And then those are gone, and then there's lollipops. Yeah. Candy continuity! Candy continuity. What happened?
然后我举起装有更多糖果的袋子，那根本不是那些东西。那是像乔利牧场主（Jolly Ranchers）之类的。是的。我知道。粉丝问题来自米歇尔·蒙格（Michelle Monge）。珍娜能决定接待处放什么糖果吗？不。我会说不。
And then I hold up bags of even more candy, which is none of those things. It's like Jolly Ranchers. Yep. I know. Fan question from Michelle Monge. Did Jenna get to decide what candy was sitting at reception? No. I'm going to say no.
他们只是给了我。但她也想知道你们多久吃一次？很多。我一直吃很多那种糖果。每个人都吃。我会生病。人们会走过来，你会以为他们是来和你说话的，
They just gave it to me. But she also wants to know how often did you guys eat it? A lot. I ate a ton of that candy all the time. Everybody did. I would get sick. People would walk up up and you would think they were coming to talk to you,
但他们只是来拿糖果的。这是真的。我记得你有时会说，哦，嘿。然后就像，就像在糖果碗里挖。我不记得你吃了很多。你有甜食瘾吗？我不觉得你有糖果甜食瘾。
but they were just coming for candy. It's true. I remember you would sometimes be like, oh, hey. And then it was just like, like digging in the candy bowl. I don't remember you eating a lot of it. Do you have a sweet tooth? I don't think of you as having a candy sweet tooth.
不。不。我没有。我们在这方面不同。我们不同。我有。好吧。所以现在迈克尔从他的办公室出来，帕姆解释说他今天不能表现得讨厌，因为孩子们要来了。名字叫帕姆。如果你讨厌的话，叫比斯利小姐。哦，抱歉。你发生服装故障了吗？
No. No. I don't. We're different that way. We're different. I do. All right. So now Michael comes out of his office and Pam explains that he cannot be nasty today because kids are coming. Name's Pam. Miss Beasley if you're nasty. Oh, I'm sorry. Are you having a wardrobe malfunction?
珍妮特·杰克逊（Janet Jackson）。你就像，不，停下。关掉它，迈克尔。关掉它。关掉它，迈克尔。关掉它。所以迈克尔非常恼火。他有一个谈话头。他说，为什么他今天会被束缚？他就像《原始》（Raw）里的艾迪·墨菲（Eddie Murphy）。他是HBO。没有限制。
Janet Jackson. You're like, no, stop it. Shut it down, Michael. Shut it down. Shut it down, Michael. Shut it down. So Michael is very annoyed. He has a talking head. He says, why is he going to be held back today? He's like Eddie Murphy in Raw. He is HBO. No limits.
没有限制。现在我们要求他成为《奶爸日托》（Daddy Daycare）里的艾迪·墨菲。不。我的意思是，我们为什么要对他这样做？我不知道。我的意思是，我喜欢他认为他的工作场所，就像一个R级内容是……应该有的地方。那就是发生的地方，是在工作中。
No limits. And now we're asking him to be Eddie Murphy in Daddy Daycare. No. I mean, why are we doing this to him? I don't know. I mean, I love that he thinks of as his workplace, as like a place where R-rated content is... Should be. That's where it happens, is at work.
他就像人力资源的噩梦。他是。所以帕姆说服迈克尔欢迎孩子们。他来到办公区。他试图欢迎他们。我不知道，他真的不感兴趣。他不感兴趣，但他试图比较，就像，让我用孩子的话说。哦，我应该把自己比作超级英雄。
He's like a human resources nightmare. He is. So Pam convinces Michael to welcome the kids. He comes out into the bullpen. He tries to welcome them. I don't know, he really is not into it. He's not into it, but he tries to compare it like, let me put this in kids speak. Oh, I should compare myself to a superhero.
所以他就像，我就像，你知道，家伙，我就像哥谭市的超人。这是唯一一次，这种情况很少发生，当吉姆和德怀特都在同一页上时。他们就像，那是蝙蝠侠。他就像，呃，好吧，我是海王。但这就像吉姆和德怀特实际上在一起。这是真的。
And so he's like, I'm like the, you know, guy, I'm like Superman in Gotham city. And it's the one time, like this happens so rarely when Jim and Dwight are both on the same page. They're like, that's Batman. And he's like, ugh, fine, I'm Aquaman. But it's like Jim and Dwight were actually like together. It's true.
在那一刻。为了那一刻纠正迈克尔。是的。好的，我们能谈谈扮演萨莎的小女孩有多可爱吗？是的。当保罗扮演的托比带她穿过厨房，然后德怀特说，你好，小家伙，你是未来。只是德怀特的想法以及他如何看待孩子，
For one moment. For that one moment to correct Michael. Yeah. Okay, can we just talk about how cute the little girl that plays Sasha is? Yeah. And when Paul, as Toby walks her through the kitchen and then Dwight's like, hello, tiny one, you are the future. Just Dwight's idea and how he sees children,
这只是让我发笑。我觉得托比在这一集里看起来是个很好的父亲。我也这么认为。是的。他有我们在这一集中看到的为人父母的人中，最温暖的父母本能。我同意。我觉得托比是个好爸爸。他可能有点悲伤，但他是个好爸爸。所以现在我们去会计部门的场景，凯文正在向艾比解释他的文件柜。
it just made me laugh. I think Toby seems like a really good father in this episode. I do too. Yeah. He has the most kind of warm parental instincts of all the people that we see parenting in this episode. I agree. I think Toby's a great dad. Warm parental instincts of all the people that we see parenting in this episode. I agree. I think Toby's a great dad. He might be a little sad, but he's a great dad. So now we go to the scene in accounting where Kevin is explaining his file cabinet to Abby.
哦，天哪。她很兴奋。她很兴奋。我的意思是，他正在给她看文件柜，但那里有一大桶M&Ms。是的。就像，为什么他不直接说，你想要一些M&Ms吗？在2分30秒，我们有一个粉丝捕捉。
Oh, man. She's thrilled. She's thrilled. I mean, he's showing her the file cabinet, but there is a giant vat of M&Ms. Yeah. Like, why doesn't he just say, do you want some M&Ms? At two minutes, 30 seconds, we had a fan catch.
好的。Fayelle123说，安吉拉在隔板的她那一侧有一张狗的照片。安吉拉，她不是唯一注意到这一点的人。米歇尔·塞克斯顿（Michelle Sexton）也注意到了。我们收到了两封关于你隔板上这张狗海报的邮件。米歇尔想知道，标志上写着什么？我试着看它，但我看不出它写着什么。好的，嗯，实际上在44秒有一个很好的截图。
Okay. Fayelle123 says, Angela has a dog photo on her side of the partition. Angela, she is not the only person who noticed this. Michelle Sexton also noticed. We got two emails about this dog poster on your partition. Michelle wants to know, what does the sign say? I tried to look at it and I couldn't tell what it says. Okay, well, actually there's a great screen grab of it at 44 seconds.
哦，好的。那只狗实际上举着一个牌子，上面写着，为食物而爱。哦，好的。那只狗实际上举着一个牌子，上面写着，为食物而爱。哦。我想这就像领养或食物捐赠之类的动物活动。你记得这个贴上去吗？为什么它突然出现在你那一侧的隔板上？
Oh, okay. The dog is actually holding up a sign and it says, will love for food. Oh, okay. The dog is actually holding up a sign and it says, will love for food. Oh. And I think it's like an adoption or like food donation or something for animals. Do you remember this going up? Why did it all of a sudden appear on your side of the petition?
是的，它通常不在那里。我会告诉你们。我不知道具体为什么这一张在那一刻贴上去，但我可以告诉你们，有时马特·佐恩（Matt Zone），我们的B摄像机操作员，或兰德尔·艾因霍恩（Randall Einhorn），A摄像机，需要拍摄会计部门，他们在这集里拍了不少。那个玻璃隔板会产生眩光。所以有时他们会战略性地在
Yeah, it wasn't normally there. And I will tell you guys this. I don't know specifically why this one went up at that moment, but I can tell you sometimes Matt Zone, our B camera operator, or Randall Einhorn, A camera, would need to be shooting and accounting, and they were quite a bit for this episode. And that glass partition would make a glare. And so sometimes they would strategically put a little piece of paper of some kind on
玻璃隔板上贴一张某种小纸片，以阻挡眩光的反射。哦，这样他们就不会在玻璃上看到自己的倒影？是的。是的。所以他们有时会那样做。所以突然间我坐下来拍戏，我会说，那是什么？
the glass partition to sort of block the bounce of that glare. Oh, so that they wouldn't get their own reflection on the glass? Yeah. Yeah. And so they did that sometime. So all of a sudden I'd sit down to do a scene and I'd be like, what is that?
这些纸都是哪来的？是的，那将是为了阻挡那种眩光，以及他们能够看到摄像机或吊杆。天哪，所以狗纸是一个眩光阻挡器。我想他们拍摄通过隔板捕捉艾比和凯文的方式，有眩光。所以他们把它贴上去了。他们经常那样做。
Where are all these papers? Yeah, and it would be to sort of block that glare and them being able to see the camera or the boom. Oh my gosh, so the dog paper was a glare blocker. I think the way they were shooting to catch Abby through the partition and Kevin, there was a glare. And so they put that up. They would often do that.
然后那就是我隔板上有随机标志的时候。你知道凯文和我，我之前说过，在办公区的所有地方，是唯一有隔板的办公桌。是的。你知道，我对此的背景故事是，我认为安吉拉·马丁要求它
And then that's when I would have random signs on the partition. And you know that Kevin and I, I've said this before, of everywhere in the bullpen were the only desk pod with a partition. Yes. And you know, my backstory for this is I think Angela Martin requested it
因为凯文很恶心。好吧，接下来我们转到凯文的谈话头，他只是说他真的希望艾比不要看他的电脑。为什么凯文这么色？这是他第二次担心他的电脑里有什么。我的意思是，凯文，你在电子邮件监控之后什么都没学到吗？我知道，但还有——
cause Kevin's disgusting. Well, next we move to Kevin's talking head where he just says he really hopes that Abby doesn't look on his computer. Why is Kevin such a perv? This is the second time he's worried about what's on his computer. I mean, Kevin, did you learn nothing after email surveillance? I know, but also-
因为凯文太恶心了。接下来我们转到凯文的访谈片段，他说他真的很希望艾比不要看他的电脑。凯文为什么这么变态？这已经是他第二次担心电脑里的东西了。我是说，凯文，邮件监控那次你什么都没学到吗？我知道，但是还有-
You didn't scrub your computer after that? Also, Kevin, just stop being gross. All right, so now Stanley introduces Michael to his daughter, Melissa. Oh, man. She's wearing some headphones. Michael says, wow, how do we explain what Michael says? He says she's a stone cold fox. Yeah, and to keep the frat boys away from her. And then she says, I'm in eighth grade. Yeah. She's a middle schooler.
你之后没把电脑清理干净吗？还有，凯文，别再恶心人了。好吧，现在斯坦利把迈克尔介绍给了他的女儿梅丽莎。天哪。她戴着耳机。迈克尔说，哇，该怎么解释迈克尔说的话呢？他说她是个冷艳美人。是啊，还要让那些兄弟会的男生离她远点。然后她说，我上八年级。是啊。她是个中学生。
Oh, Michael, that was really awkward. This moves us into Michael's talking head where he says, this is a quote that a lot of people emailed about. He says, it's not that children make me uncomfortable, it's just why be a dad when you can be a fun uncle? And a lot of people thought that this was a continuity error because we've heard so much about how Michael wants a family and wants to have kids and they were saying, why does Michael say that he doesn't want to be a dad? Oh, no, he's not saying that he's, he's compensating for the fact that he's not a dad. He's just giving himself a pep talk. Yeah. All Michael wants to do is have a family for sure.
哦，迈克尔，那真的很尴尬。这让我们进入了迈克尔的采访环节，他说，这是很多人发邮件询问的一句台词。他说，并不是孩子们让我感到不舒服，只是既然能当个有趣的叔叔，为什么非要当爸爸呢？很多人认为这是一个连续性错误，因为我们听过太多关于迈克尔想要一个家庭、想要孩子的说法，他们说，为什么迈克尔会说他不想当爸爸？哦，不，他不是那个意思，他是在弥补自己不是爸爸的事实。他只是在给自己打气。是啊。迈克尔一心只想拥有一个家庭，这是肯定的。
For sure. And I think in this moment, he's just like trying to put a good spin on where his life is at for himself. I think so too. Yeah. I think so too. It kind of made me sad because you know that's not really where his heart's at. Oh, well. Just wait.
肯定的。我觉得在那一刻，他只是想为自己目前的生活状态找个好听的说法。我也这么认为。是啊。我也这么认为。这让我有点难过，因为你知道那并不是他内心真正的想法。哦，好吧。等着瞧吧。
I know. It gets sadder. I mean, I sobbed twice during this episode. We'll get to that. At three minutes, 31 seconds, we meet Jake, Meredith's son. Yeah. Meredith's son.
我知道。会更难过的。我是说，这集我哭了两回。我们待会儿再说。在3分31秒，我们见到了杰克，梅雷迪斯的儿子。是啊。梅雷迪斯的儿子。
Meredith's son, a hard thing to say. He was suspended from school. He's kind of a rascal. That's son. Meredith's son. A hard thing to say. He was suspended from school. He's kind of a rascal. That's a nice way to put it. I know. I wrote a different word. It rhymes with smashmo.
梅雷迪斯的儿子，这很难说出口。他被学校停课了。他是个捣蛋鬼。那是儿子。梅雷迪斯的儿子。这很难说出口。他被学校停课了。他是个捣蛋鬼。这说法还挺委婉的。我知道。我写了另一个词。和“smashmo”押韵。
But yeah, he's just not nice. And I'm like, I mean, he's like throwing things at people. Yeah. He's like a name-caller. Insulting people. I know. His shirt. Did you see what his shirt says? Yes.
但确实，他就是不讨人喜欢。我是说，他会朝别人扔东西。是啊。他还会骂人。侮辱别人。我知道。他的衬衫。你看到他衬衫上写什么了吗？看到了。
It says something like, I have already forgotten your name. Yes, that's what it says. I mean, Meredith. Meredith. Why are you letting him walk around with that on? Yeah. Okay, so the next scene I love, it's three minutes, 44 seconds.
上面写着类似“我已经忘了你的名字”之类的话。是的，就是这么写的。我是说，梅雷迪斯。梅雷迪斯。你为什么让他穿着那件衣服到处走？是啊。好吧，下一场戏我很喜欢，在3分44秒。
We're in the conference room. We're setting up for something. It looks like there might be a party aspect to the stay. It's you, Kelly and Ryan. Kelly's helping me put a tablecloth on the conference room table. I just want to say, remember in the Christmas episode when Pam is not helping you put it on?
我们在会议室。我们正在为某事做准备。看起来这天好像有个派对。是你、凯利和瑞安。凯利在帮我把桌布铺在会议室的桌子上。我只想说，还记得圣诞节那集吗，帕姆没帮你铺桌布？
Kelly is also not really helping you put it on. Anytime there's a party, I totally relate to Angela because you guys are a bunch of jerks that don't really help. I have a feeling that every time we try to help you with that tablecloth, you yell at us. I don't think so. And that's why we're not helping you with it. I don't think so.
凯利其实也没怎么帮你铺。每次有派对，我都特别能理解安吉拉，因为你们这群混蛋根本不帮忙。我有一种感觉，每次我们想帮你铺桌布，你都会对我们大吼大叫。我不这么认为。这就是我们不帮你的原因。我不这么认为。
You probably nitpick how we're doing it. Why does no one help you with the tablecloth? Because you're a bunch of slackers. Nope. You're a bunch of slackers. Because you'll say, you're about to shoot down a child. And so I'm just saying. Anyway.
你可能会挑剔我们做得怎么样。为什么没人帮你铺桌布？因为你们是一群懒鬼。不对。你们是一群懒鬼。因为你会说，你快要训斥一个孩子了。所以我只是说说而已。总之。
This might be why it's all on you. She's trying to set up for this party. Ryan and Kelly aren't helping. No. Kelly's looking at Ryan. Ryan's like, don't look at me. And I'm in the meantime like, eh. Anyway, Toby walks in with Sasha, his daughter.
这可能就是为什么活儿全落你一个人身上了。她正试图为派对做准备。瑞安和凯利没帮忙。没有。凯利在看瑞安。瑞安说，别看我。与此同时，我心想，呃。总之，托比带着他的女儿萨莎走了进来。
And she very sweetly says, can I help? So sweet. So sweet. So sweet. Angela's like, no, no. I'd have to explain everything to you, but no. And then Kelly, I look at Kelly and I'm like, no. And I love Paul's delivery of like, well, I didn't see it going that way.
她很甜美地说，我能帮忙吗？太可爱了。太可爱了。太可爱了。安吉拉说，不，不。我得给你解释所有事情，还是算了。然后凯利，我看着凯利，心想，不。我很喜欢保罗的表演，他说，嗯，我没想到会这样。
Yeah. He's like, it's not what I was expecting. That's not what I was expecting. Yes. I love that scene. Kelly was so excited. She's like, I love babies. Not what I was expecting. Yes. I love that scene. Kelly was so excited. She's like, I love babies. I can't wait to have babies.
是啊。他说，这不是我预料到的。这不是我预料到的。是的。我很喜欢那场戏。凯利太兴奋了。她说，我喜欢婴儿。这不是我预料到的。是的。我很喜欢那场戏。凯利太兴奋了。她说，我喜欢婴儿。我迫不及待想生孩子了。
Ryan is really funny in this episode. BJ is great. He has some really funny moments. And he's just like, basically, Kelly, just her idea of hooking up is just having babies with me as soon as possible. Well, his talking head, he's like, Kelly and I agreed we were just going to have fun.
瑞安在这一集里非常搞笑。BJ演得太棒了。他有一些非常有趣的时刻。他基本上就是觉得，凯利对“约会”的定义就是尽快和我生孩子。嗯，他的采访环节，他说，凯利和我商量好只是玩玩而已。
But what I'm realizing is that fun for Kelly means getting married and having babies as soon as possible with me. So that's her definition of having fun. And don't hook up with anyone like that on February 13th. That's right. I like your line in this scene, Angela. I get quoted this a lot. When she asked me if I would like to have kids and I say, well, maybe some small, well-behaved
但我意识到，对凯利来说，“玩玩”意味着结婚并尽快和我生孩子。这就是她对“玩玩”的定义。2月13号那天可别和这种人约会。没错。安吉拉，我很喜欢你在这场戏里的台词。我经常被问到这句话。当她问我是否想要孩子时，我说，嗯，也许是一些小巧、乖巧的
boys. Yeah. So weird. Small, well-behaved boys. Small. I don't want big boys. Apparently, I want tiny, petite boys. All right.
男孩。是啊。太奇怪了。小巧、乖巧的男孩。小巧。我不想要大男孩。显然，我想要娇小玲珑的男孩。好吧。
So next up, Michael is on the phone to corporate and Toby's daughter, Sasha, walks in. Yeah. Then she leaves, but then she comes back later and starts playing with his toy train. They're so sweet together. So sweet. Michael's so tickled. He's having such a great time with her.
接下来，迈克尔正在给总公司打电话，托比的女儿萨莎走了进来。是啊。然后她离开了，但后来又回来了，开始玩他的玩具火车。他们在一起真可爱。真可爱。迈克尔被逗乐了。他和她玩得很开心。
I know, they do the train whistle. And he really, Steve, when we were filming that, Steve actually kept making the kids crack up. Do you remember that? I remember how hard it was for Haley to keep a straight face and Delaney too, Steve was cracking her up. It was really sweet. But we had a couple fan questions about that.
我知道，他们吹了火车哨。史蒂夫在拍摄那场戏时，真的总是把孩子们逗得大笑。你还记得吗？我记得海莉很难忍住不笑，德莱尼也是，史蒂夫把她逗得大笑。真的很可爱。但我们收到了一些关于那场戏的粉丝提问。
Katie Procedo said, I always love episodes where we get to see Michael interacting with kids because you can just tell that Steve Carell likes being around kids. He's a great dad. He is. And Beth White said, is Steve really this good with kids in real life? Yes a great dad. He is. And Beth White said, is Steve really this good with kids in real life?
凯蒂·普罗塞多说，我总是很喜欢迈克尔与孩子们互动的剧集，因为你能看出史蒂夫·卡瑞尔很喜欢和孩子在一起。他是个好爸爸。他是。贝丝·怀特说，史蒂夫在现实生活中真的这么擅长带孩子吗？是的，他是个好爸爸。他是。贝丝·怀特说，史蒂夫在现实生活中真的这么擅长带孩子吗？
Yes. He is. He is. He is. The kids were so tickled by him. He's a sweetheart. And we should say, you mentioned earlier, Angela, how families would sometimes come and visit.
是的。他是。他是。他是。孩子们被他逗得很开心。他是个大好人。我们应该说，安吉拉，你之前提到过，家属有时会来探班。
Steve was such a great ambassador for the show. He would always go into our green room and meet the families and take the kids on a little tour and show them his office. Take pictures. Yes. Well, I think now Pam is going to try to get Abby to help her shred some old documents. Shut down. Pam gets shut down. No, Abby's reading on the couch in reception. But then Jim says, hey, I've read that book. the couch in reception. But then Jim says, Hey, I've read that book. They have a little banter. They bond? Yeah. Abby agrees to help him with sales. Now, I want to say something here.
史蒂夫是剧组非常棒的形象大使。他总是会去我们的休息室见家属，带孩子们参观一下，给他们看他的办公室。拍照。是的。好吧，我想现在帕姆要试着让艾比帮她粉碎一些旧文件。被拒绝了。帕姆被拒绝了。不，艾比在接待处的沙发上看书。但吉姆说，嘿，我看过那本书。在接待处的沙发上。但吉姆说，嘿，我看过那本书。他们聊了几句。他们建立起联系了？是啊。艾比同意帮他做销售。现在，我想在这里说点什么。
Okay. I feel a soap box coming. It's tiny. It's a very, it's a small opinion. Okay. Observation. Okay. Observation. Okay. Jim knows that it's Pam's goal to befriend a kid, but rather than help her bond with Abby, he just kind of shows off and steals Abby away. I think this is hurt feelings Pam talking because- But did you notice?
好吧。我觉得我要开始说教了。很短。这是一个很小的观点。好吧。观察。好吧。观察。好吧。吉姆知道帕姆的目标是和一个孩子交朋友，但他没有帮她和艾比建立联系，而是有点炫耀，把艾比抢走了。我觉得这是帕姆在闹情绪，因为——但你注意到了吗？
I mean, I thought that was a little bit of like. Passive aggressive? I don't know what it is, but it was a little bit of like, come on, it's not that hard, I can do it. Like, like Jim. Watch me bond with a kid. So it's like a competition. Oh yes, it felt a little bit weirdly competitive.
我是说，我觉得那有点像。被动攻击？我不知道那是什么，但有点像，“来吧，这没那么难，我能做到。”就像，就像吉姆。看我怎么和一个孩子打成一片。所以这就像一场比赛。哦，是的，感觉有点奇怪的竞争意味。
Hmm, okay. Do you not see that? Well, I guess I do. I guess I also just thought Jim was being really nice. No, he knows Pam's goal. And I think if he were really being nice at the end of that whole spiel, he would have said, and Pam, why don't you join us?
嗯，好吧。你没看出来吗？嗯，我想我看到了。我想我也只是觉得吉姆表现得真的很友善。不，他知道帕姆的目标。我觉得如果他真的想表现得友善，在整段话结束时，他会说，“帕姆，你要不要加入我们？”
Or he might've said, do you know who else loves books? Pam? Yes, yes. This is what I'm saying. He doesn't help facilitate anything. He just comes in and shows off. Maybe it's not his job to help Pam. It is.
或者他可能会说，“你知道还有谁喜欢书吗？帕姆？”是的，是的。这就是我想说的。他没有帮忙促成任何事情。他只是走过来炫耀。也许帮帕姆不是他的工作。是他的工作。
It is his job to help her. Pam is not his responsibility. Pam is getting married. He's ticked off. See, that's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying. That's what's underneath it. See, before they got in all these little fights and all the wedding date was set, I think
帮她是他的工作。帕姆不是他的责任。帕姆要结婚了。他很生气。看，这就是我想说的。这就是我想说的。这就是底层的逻辑。看，在他们陷入这些小争吵、婚期定下来之前，我觉得
Jim would have facilitated. Maybe. But now he's like, boundary Jim. Now he's like, I have boundaries. I don't help you anymore because I'm not your fiance. Also, maybe I'm practicing self care, Pam. Wow. See what side you're on.
吉姆会帮忙促成的。也许吧。但现在他就像是，“界限吉姆”。现在他就像是，“我有界限。我不再帮你，因为我不是你的未婚夫。”而且，也许我在练习自我关怀，帕姆。哇。看看你站在哪一边。
Okay. Okay. Okay. Here we go. Well, let's talk about how Dwight is doing with the kids. Okay. Let's. Abby is hanging out with Jim and Jim's doing that thing where, you know, she's shaking his hand. He's like, oh man, you're crushing me.
好吧。好吧。好吧。我们开始吧。好吧，我们来谈谈德怀特和孩子们相处得怎么样。好吧。艾比和吉姆在一起，吉姆在做那个动作，你知道，她正在和他握手。他说，哦天哪，你要把我捏碎了。
Oh wait, I watched this with Isabel. And so when Dwight's like, you're not even, she's not that tough. I'll show you. She's like, what is wrong with Dwight, Mom? He's so literal. He is. He is childlike himself. It's true. It's true. And then after that, Merida's son comes over to Dwight's desk and starts touching all his bobbleheads.
哦等等，我和伊莎贝尔一起看了这一集。所以当德怀特说，“你甚至……她没那么强。我给你演示一下。”她说，“妈妈，德怀特怎么了？他太死板了。”他是。他自己就像个孩子。是真的。是真的。在那之后，梅雷迪斯的儿子走到德怀特的办公桌前，开始摸他所有的摇头娃娃。
Hold up. Where's the Dwight bobblehead? Well, Melinda Maggercuth would like to know that as well. Seven minutes, one second. Where is Angela's gift to Dwight? Thank you, Melinda. I am hoping, Melinda, that Dwight saw all those children there and feared for its safety and with loving care locked it in his drawer. He has one drawer that locks. It's on the left side of his desk and I hope it's locked there for safety. You know what? Let's say that that's where it is. During this scene, Meredith's son refers to Meredith as Meredith. And Dwight is Mr. Poop.
等等。德怀特的摇头娃娃在哪？嗯，梅琳达·马格库斯也想知道这一点。7分01秒。安吉拉送给德怀特的礼物在哪？谢谢你，梅琳达。我希望，梅琳达，德怀特看到那里有那么多孩子，担心它的安全，于是小心翼翼地把它锁进了抽屉里。他有一个能锁的抽屉。就在他办公桌的左侧，我希望它为了安全被锁在那里了。你知道吗？我们就当它在那儿吧。在这场戏中，梅雷迪斯的儿子称呼梅雷迪斯为“梅雷迪斯”。而德怀特是“大便先生”。
Yeah. He's being a jerk. He's being a jerk. And Jim and Abby laugh. Oh, they think it's so funny. They're like, now they're like totally in cahoots. I loved when Sasha goes up to Phyllis and says, are you Mother Goose?
是啊。他真是个混蛋。他真是个混蛋。吉姆和艾比笑了。哦，他们觉得这太搞笑了。他们就像，现在他们完全是一伙的了。我很喜欢萨莎走到菲利斯面前说，“你是鹅妈妈吗？”
Yes. We were also tickled by that when we read it at the table read. I remember I laughed so hard at that observation. If anyone should ever be cast as Mother Goose, it is Phyllis. And Phyllis's reaction, though, is so brilliant. And so Isabel and I were watching it together. So we went and we wanted to see
是的。我们在剧本朗读会上读到这一段时也被逗乐了。我记得我对那个观察结果笑得很大声。如果有人应该被选为鹅妈妈，那一定是菲利斯。不过，菲利斯的反应太精彩了。伊莎贝尔和我一起看的时候，我们想看看
what a picture of Mother Goose looked like. Does it look like Phyllis? It looks like Phyllis. 100%, 100%. You're showing me a drawing of Mother Goose and it looks like Phyllis. And she's even like wearing purple. You know what I mean?
鹅妈妈的照片长什么样。看起来像菲利斯吗？看起来像菲利斯。100%，100%。你给我看了一张鹅妈妈的画，它看起来就像菲利斯。而且她甚至穿着紫色。你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah. I know, Phyllis was wearing purple in the scene this whole episode. I wondered if they sort of looked at photos. She was always in purple. She was in purple a lot. If you went to Phyllis's house and looked in her closet, it would just be purple outfits. And lots of like beaded jewelry. Yes. Always some beaded necklace. Okay. It's so true. And I just realized. What? You kind of took your daughter to work.
是啊。我知道，菲利斯在这一整集的戏里都穿着紫色。我怀疑他们是不是参考了照片。她总是穿紫色。她经常穿紫色。如果你去菲利斯家，翻翻她的衣柜，里面肯定全是紫色的衣服。还有很多珠子首饰。是的。总是戴着珠子项链。好吧。太真实了。我刚意识到。什么？你算是带女儿去上班了。
I did. Oh, cause she watched the episode with me. So she watched it with you. Yes, I guess I did. You took your daughter to work for Take Your Daughter to Work Day. For office ladies. Yeah.
我带了。哦，因为她和我一起看了这一集。所以她和你一起看了。是的，我想我带了。你带女儿参加了“带女儿上班日”。为了《办公室女郎》。是啊。
I did. That's kind of sweet. That's so funny. All right, seven minutes, 53 seconds. We're back in the kitchen and Melissa and Ryan are talking. And Melissa's like, so I thought it was really funny in sort of the way they wrote her eighth grade brain to try to impress Ryan is that she just drinks coffee all day.
我带了。那真可爱。太搞笑了。好吧，7分53秒。我们回到厨房，梅丽莎和瑞安在聊天。梅丽莎说，我觉得他们写她八年级大脑试图给瑞安留下深刻印象的方式很有趣，就是她整天都在喝咖啡。
Yeah. The ice, matcha latte, whatever, all day. Yeah, she can't get enough of them. Yeah. Ryan, you're such a dork. You haven't been to Jitters? Oh my god, give me your phone number. He's like, ugh. Yeah, speaking of Jitters at Steamtown Mall. So Steamtown Mall is a real place.
是啊。冰抹茶拿铁，什么的，整天都在喝。是啊，她喝不够。是啊。瑞安，你真是个书呆子。你没去过Jitters吗？哦天哪，把你的电话号码给我。他说，呃。是啊，说到Steamtown购物中心的Jitters。所以Steamtown购物中心是个真实的地方。
Yeah, we've been there. The center of the city of Scranton. Yeah. I could not find a Jitters today or in the past. I spent a good 40 minutes looking for it. Well, that's 40 minutes of your life. You're never getting back. I'm never getting back. But guys, if there is or ever was a jitters, will you let me know because Jenna needs that 40 minutes back. I just need to validate. Yeah. Validate that 40 minutes. Well, during this whole conversation about jitters in the kitchen, Kelly is vicious. Kelly is the type of gal that if you step on her territory, like her man's space in any way, she's gonna burn you to the ground.
是啊，我们去过那里。斯克兰顿市的中心。是啊。我今天或者过去都没找到Jitters。我花了整整40分钟找它。好吧，那是你生命中永远找不回来的40分钟。我永远找不回来了。但伙计们，如果那里有或者曾经有过Jitters，请告诉我，因为珍娜需要那40分钟回来。我只是需要验证一下。是啊。验证那40分钟。好吧，在厨房里关于Jitters的整个谈话中，凯利非常恶毒。凯利是那种如果你侵犯了她的领地，比如她男人的空间，她会把你彻底摧毁的人。
And she does. She decimates Ryan. She goes and tattles immediately to Stanley. She points, she was like, I have something fishy going on over there. I don't know, they're talking a lot. I've been watching them all day. Yeah.
她确实这么做了。她把瑞安毁了。她立刻去向斯坦利告状。她指着说，她就像，“那边有点猫腻。我不知道，他们聊了很多。我盯着他们看了一整天。”是啊。
And Stanley is pissed. Okay, this leads us to the scene that we got more mail than any other scene in this episode. Okay. The scene when Stanley confronts Ryan in the break room. This was called out as many people's favorite fan question from Chris Johnson. How many takes did it take to get the Stanley Ryan scene?
斯坦利气疯了。好吧，这引出了我们这一集收到邮件最多的一场戏。好吧。斯坦利在休息室质问瑞安的那场戏。这是克里斯·约翰逊提到的许多人最喜欢的粉丝提问。斯坦利和瑞安的那场戏拍了多少次？
I tried to text Leslie. We need to get Leslie in here. We do. I tried to reach out to him. Hopefully we'll hear back. He's traveling right now. He's traveling. OK.
我试着给莱斯利发短信。我们需要把莱斯利请来。我们会的。我试着联系他。希望我们能收到回复。他现在在旅行。他在旅行。好的。
So I know from the bloopers, because there are great bloopers on YouTube of this, that he completely like made BJ lose it. Oh yeah, season two bloopers at the three minute mark. I watched it as well. Okay, Stanley is letting Ryan have it. Leslie improvised a ton, that whole thing with like, Jesus isn't gonna help you, none of them are gonna help you.
所以我从花絮中知道，因为YouTube上有很棒的这一段花絮，他完全让BJ笑场了。哦，是的，第二季花絮在3分钟处。我也看了。好吧，斯坦利在教训瑞安。莱斯利即兴发挥了很多，整段关于“耶稣帮不了你，他们谁也帮不了你”的话。
He was fantastic in that scene. And now we're going back to the conference room and Dwight is playing the recorder for the kids and he's got this on the table. He's got corn husks and plates and cups ribbons and things. There's going to be some kind of crafting project. Yeah. I had a fan question from Laura. Okay. Rain's recorder playing is top notch. Did he really play the recorder or was it added in later? No, he really played that.
他在那场戏里太棒了。现在我们回到会议室，德怀特正在为孩子们吹竖笛，桌上有玉米皮、盘子、杯子、丝带之类的东西。看来要进行某种手工制作项目。是啊。我有一个来自劳拉的粉丝提问。好吧。雷恩的竖笛吹得太棒了。他是真的在吹竖笛，还是后来加进去的？不，他真的是在吹。
Yeah. He played the bassoon in high school. Yeah. He plays the recorder again in the bird funeral. Yes. When Pam sings along. Mm-hmm. So Rain is recorder proficient.
是啊。他高中时吹过巴松管。是啊。他在“鸟儿葬礼”那集又吹了竖笛。是的。当帕姆跟着唱的时候。嗯哼。所以雷恩很精通竖笛。
He is a recorder player. Yeah. He is. Now, he's also reading a book. Wait, wait. Before we get to that. Oh. hold up. This is big.
他是个竖笛演奏者。是啊。他是。现在，他还在看书。等等，等等。在我们谈到那个之前。哦。等等。这很重要。
This is one of my biggest cards of this episode. What is it? Might not be saying much. This is a big card for me. He finishes playing the song and he goes, that was Green Sleeves. It's an English ballad written about the beheading of Anne Boleyn.
这是我这一集最大的卡片之一。是什么？可能说明不了什么。这对我很重要。他吹完那首歌，说，“那是《绿袖子》。这是一首关于安妮·博林被斩首的英国民谣。”
Okay, so you know I did a term paper on Anne Boleyn. In college? I love Anne Boleyn, no, in high school. Oh. Yes, in high I did a term paper on Ambalin. In college. I love Ambalin. No, in high school. Oh. Yes, in high school. Senior term paper. But I looked up Green Sleeves. Okay.
好吧，你知道我写过一篇关于安妮·博林的学期论文。在大学里？我喜欢安妮·博林，不，在高中。哦。是的，在高中我写过一篇关于安妮·博林的学期论文。在大学里。我喜欢安妮·博林。不，在高中。哦。是的，在高中。高三学期论文。但我查了《绿袖子》。好吧。
This was fascinating to me. Sorry about to geek out on you guys a little bit. There is a persistent belief that Green Sleeves was composed by Henry VIII for his lover Ambalin. Here's what really threw me for a loop. Ready? Yeah. There's this other me for a loop. Ready? Yeah. There's this other interpretation of the lyrics. Ready? Yeah.
这让我很着迷。抱歉要给你们科普一下。有一种持续的信念认为《绿袖子》是亨利八世为他的情人安妮·博林创作的。这是真正让我感到困惑的地方。准备好了吗？是啊。还有另一种让我困惑的地方。准备好了吗？是啊。还有另一种对歌词的解读。准备好了吗？是啊。
Lady green sleeves was a promiscuous young woman, even perhaps a prostitute. Okay. At the time, the word green had sexual connotations, most notably in the phrase, a green gown, a reference to the grass stains on a woman's dress from engaging in sexual intercourse in a field somewhere. Green is kind of horish. Green is kind of horish. This justifies that whole line for Angela Martin. I freaked out.
“绿袖子女士”是一个放荡的年轻女子，甚至可能是一个妓女。好吧。当时，“绿色”这个词有性暗示，最著名的是短语“绿色长裙”，指女性在田野里进行性行为时裙子上沾上的草渍。绿色有点像“荡妇”。绿色有点像“荡妇”。这证明了安吉拉·马丁的那整句台词。我吓坏了。
I was in my That's What She Said and I'm like, green is horish. I'm sure my neighbors are like, what is happening? Lady, green was like a dirty color. Great find, Angela. Thank you. That is some deep diving, historian type work. On the internet. To prove a reference line from the office. Well done.
我当时在我的“这就是她说的”环节，我心想，绿色是“荡妇”。我敢肯定我的邻居们在想，发生了什么事？女士，绿色就像一种肮脏的颜色。好发现，安吉拉。谢谢。那是历史学家类型的工作。在互联网上。为了证明《办公室》里的一句台词。干得好。
Thank you. I give you this. Thank you. I give you this. Thank you. I want to give you that. I take that. I take that.
谢谢。我给你这个。谢谢。我给你这个。谢谢。我想给你那个。我接受。我接受。
All right. So also in this scene, he is reading a book called Struwell Peter. We had a fan question from Tyler O'Donnell. Was the story that Dwight reads the kids a real folk tale or was it something the writers made up? Gang, it's real. It's real. Loosely translated, it means shaggy Peter. It was a German.
好吧。所以在这场戏里，他还在读一本叫《蓬头彼得》的书。我们有一个来自泰勒·奥唐奈的粉丝提问。德怀特读给孩子们听的故事是真实的民间传说，还是编剧编出来的？伙计们，它是真的。它是真的。粗略翻译过来，意思是“蓬头彼得”。它是一本德国的。
What? That sounds dirty. Don't wave your shaggy Peter at me. It sounds inappropriate. It does. Okay, so it's a story about shaggy Peter. I went out last night and this guy had such a shaggy Peter. Jenna. We're gonna get the E.
什么？听起来很脏。别拿你的“蓬头彼得”对着我挥舞。听起来很不合适。确实。好吧，这是一个关于蓬头彼得的故事。我昨晚出去，那个家伙有一个如此蓬头的彼得。珍娜。我们要被禁了。
All right. Okay, so. It is a German book of cautionary tales for children. All right. Okay, written by Heinrich Hoffmann in 1845. Now, I found this fascinating. Heinrich Hoffmann wanted to get a Christmas present for his three-year-old son. Okay.
好吧。好吧，所以。这是一本德国的儿童警示故事书。好吧。好吧，由海因里希·霍夫曼于1845年编写。现在，我觉得这很迷人。海因里希·霍夫曼想给三岁的儿子买一份圣诞礼物。好吧。
And he could not find a good children's book. I'm sorry, Heinrich. So he wrote his own. He wrote it himself. About Shaggy Peter. Yes. He wrote Struwellpeter. Struwellpeter. And it was so sort of popular, I guess, among people that Heinrich knew that it was eventually published. Let's cut off their thumbs. Yeah, exactly. It's in the story.
但他找不到一本好的儿童读物。抱歉，海因里希。所以他自己写了一本。他自己写的。关于蓬头彼得。是的。他写了《蓬头彼得》。而且它在海因里希认识的人中很受欢迎，最终出版了。让我们切掉他们的拇指。是啊，没错。故事里有。
Here's a super crazy fact. What? In 1891, Mark Twain wrote a translation of this book that he called Slavinly Peter. Slavinly Peter. Yes, which was published, but not until 1935, 25 years after Mark Twain died. And you and I are gonna write our version called Shaggy Pete.
这是一个超级疯狂的事实。什么？1891年，马克·吐温翻译了这本书，他称之为《邋遢彼得》。《邋遢彼得》。是的，它出版了，但直到1935年，也就是马克·吐温去世25年后才出版。你和我将要写我们的版本，叫《蓬头皮特》。
There are 10 stories in this book. So in addition to the thumb sucking story that Dwight reads the kids, which is true and in the book, there is also a story about a little girl who plays with matches, accidentally lights herself on fire and dies. Then there's the story of a boy who doesn't want to eat his soup for dinner. He holds out for five days and then starves to death. And dies. Do all the kids die or get maimed?
这本书里有10个故事。所以除了德怀特读给孩子们听的那个吸吮拇指的故事（那是真的，书里有）之外，还有一个关于一个小女孩玩火柴，不小心把自己点着并死掉的故事。然后是一个男孩不想吃晚餐的汤的故事。他坚持了五天，然后饿死了。并死掉了。所有的孩子都死掉或致残了吗？
No, not all of them. Some of them live through their rebellions. But are forever like? Sort of maimed or sort of just, you know. Not the same emotionally. Kind of, yeah. Well, that's fun. Yeah.
不，不是所有。有些人从他们的叛逆中活了下来。但永远像是？有点致残，或者只是，你知道。情感上不再一样了。有点，是啊。好吧，那真有趣。是啊。
Oh my god. So that's the book, it's real. Well, we really get a window into Dwight and Angela's childhoods in this episode. Oh yeah. I mean, Dwight grew up reading these stories with his grandmother. Yes.
哦天哪。所以那本书是真的。好吧，我们在这一集里真的看到了德怀特和安吉拉的童年。哦，是的。我是说，德怀特从小就是听着这些故事长大的。是的。
And then Angela is like, listen, my father was a strict disciplinarian, so you better whip these kids into shape. That's right. So they are a perfect match. I say it over and over. That's right. They are a perfect match. I say it over and over. They really are. They really are.
然后安吉拉说，“听着，我父亲是个严厉的纪律执行者，所以你最好把这些孩子管教好。”没错。所以他们是天生一对。我一遍又一遍地说。没错。他们是天生一对。我一遍又一遍地说。他们真的是。他们真的是。
At 9 minutes 47 seconds, we do pan to the table where Dwight has laid out supplies to make corn husk dolls. No one ever makes them, but the supplies are there. We had a fan question from Lauren Page, who actually made the corn husk dolls that Dwight plans to make with the kids? Was it Phil Shea? I would say Phil Shea. It was Lauren. Phil Shea was responsible for all of those items
在9分47秒，我们确实切换到了桌子，德怀特在那里摆放了制作玉米皮娃娃的材料。没人真的做，但材料都在那儿。我们有一个来自劳伦·佩奇的粉丝提问，德怀特计划和孩子们一起做的玉米皮娃娃是谁做的？是菲尔·谢吗？我会说是菲尔·谢。是劳伦。菲尔·谢负责桌上所有的那些物品。
on the table. Phil Shea is a jack of many trades. Like he really had to do a lot. He does. I just love it that now our questions come in with like specifics. Like, am I spotting a Phil Shea moment? Yes, Lauren, you're spotting a Phil Shea moment. I think we should take a little break because Michael is about to give the kids a tour of
菲尔·谢是个多面手。他真的做了很多。他做了。我只是喜欢现在我们的问题变得如此具体。比如，我是不是发现了一个菲尔·谢时刻？是的，劳伦，你发现了一个菲尔·谢时刻。我想我们应该休息一下，因为迈克尔马上要带孩子们参观
the office and I think that deserves its own space. Right. It's really sweet. It's sweet. Let's take a break. Take a break. All right, we're back. We got some food. There's a bagel bar. Angela's eating an everything bagel. With as much butter as I could put on it. Don't judge me. What? Don't judge me.
办公室了，我觉得那值得单独留出空间。对。真的很可爱。很可爱。休息一下。休息一下。好吧，我们回来了。我们吃了一些食物。有一个百吉饼吧。安吉拉正在吃一个全料百吉饼。抹上了我能抹的所有黄油。别评判我。什么？别评判我。
Okay, we won't judge you because we can't understand you. I love butter. Okay. Angela, before we get started, I wanna take a moment because I feel like there's something I have to say to you. Is this like a, do I need a glass of wine moment?
好吧，我们不会评判你，因为我们听不懂你在说什么。我喜欢黄油。好吧。安吉拉，在我们开始之前，我想花点时间，因为我觉得有些话我必须对你说。这是那种，我需要一杯红酒的时刻吗？
Like, is it that big of a moment or am I okay with my bagel and butter? You're fine with your bagel and butter. Okay. I feel like it's something that I need to say. I'm saying it reluctantly yet with enthusiasm. Is it about my hair today? Nope. Okay.
它是那种重大的时刻，还是我吃着百吉饼和黄油就行了？你吃着百吉饼和黄油就行了。好吧。我觉得有些话我必须说。我很不情愿但又充满热情地说出来。是关于我今天的头发吗？不是。好吧。
It's not about your hair. All right. I'm going to say it. I'm going to say it. But once I say it, it's been said. I love Game of Thrones. Yes! Yes! I told you you would. I told you you would. Where are you? What's happened? End of season one.
不是关于你的头发。好吧。我要说了。我要说了。但一旦我说出来，它就说出来了。我喜欢《权力的游戏》。是的！是的！我告诉过你会喜欢的。我告诉过你会喜欢的。你在哪？发生了什么？第一季结束。
Spoilers. End of season one. Oh, you you would. Where are you? What's happened? Spoilers, spoilers. End of season one. Oh, Khaleesi out of the fire. I mean, Angela. With her dragons. When Khaleesi rises out of the fire. I am Khaleesi, first of my name, mother of dragons. She's got three baby dragons on her?
剧透。第一季结束。哦，你……你在哪？发生了什么？剧透，剧透。第一季结束。哦，卡丽熙从火中走出来。我是说，安吉拉。带着她的龙。当卡丽熙从火中升起时。我是卡丽熙，我名下的第一位，龙之母。她身上有三条小龙？
Yeah. I was like, I was like, oh my God, I am Khaleesi with three baby dragons and my dragons are just gonna get bigger. I was like, I'm a woman coming into her own. I'm with you, Khaleesi. Everyone out there who was really, I got a lot of mail and support from people out there
是啊。我当时心想，哦天哪，我是带着三条小龙的卡丽熙，我的龙只会越来越大。我心想，我是一个正在成长的女人。我和你在一起，卡丽熙。外面所有那些真的，我收到了很多邮件支持那些人
who were like, Jenna, you do not need to watch Game of Thrones, you do not need to, like we were in it together, I feel like I'm letting some folks down. You told me it was a soap opera, a fantasy soap opera. Well, it is a fantasy soap opera, Angela. A little bit, a little bit. But it's more than that.
他们说，“珍娜，你不需要看《权力的游戏》，你不需要……”就像我们在一起一样，我觉得我让一些人失望了。你告诉我那是一部肥皂剧，一部奇幻肥皂剧。好吧，它确实是一部奇幻肥皂剧，安吉拉。有一点，有一点。但它不仅仅是那样。
Well, you know what? I'm just gonna say that I was wrong about it, but I do, I'm gonna stand by the Star Wars. Okay, okay, you know what? I'll take it, I'll take it. I got one, I got one. I got GOT with you. Yeah.
好吧，你知道吗？我只想说我之前错了，但我会坚持《星球大战》。好吧，好吧，你知道吗？我接受，我接受。我和你一起看《权力的游戏》。是啊。
I'm good. I'm in it, I'm in it to win it on GOT. Okay. Michael takes the kids over to Creed. Okay. And he says, this is Creed. He's in charge of something. Right. And Creed says, that is correct. Yeah. Because Creed doesn't know what he's in charge of. Creed doesn't know either, no one knows. And then of course Creed is like the showstopper crowd pleaser when he's like, wanna see a foot with four toes. Yeah.
我很好。我加入了，我加入了《权力的游戏》。好吧。迈克尔带孩子们去找克里德。好吧。他说，“这是克里德。他负责某件事。”对。克里德说，“那是正确的。”是啊。因为克里德不知道他负责什么。克里德也不知道，没人知道。然后当然，克里德是那种当他说“想看一只四根脚趾的脚吗”时，能让全场沸腾的人。是啊。
And they're so excited and Creed is giddy. Creed can't wait to show him. Finally, someone wants to see his four toes. I know. But he says, don't worry, like the hair covers up most of it. I know. What is it, hobbit feet?
他们太兴奋了，克里德很激动。克里德迫不及待地想给他们看。终于有人想看他的四根脚趾了。我知道。但他又说，“别担心，头发盖住了大部分。”我知道。那是霍比特人的脚吗？
I guess so. Hobbit, Jenna, Lord of the Rings. I'm sorry. I'm not going to go there. I know. I'm not going to. I shouldn't have brought it up. That I will.
我想是吧。霍比特人，珍娜，《指环王》。抱歉。我不会去那里的。我知道。我不会的。我不该提起的。我会的。
I mean, I might watch a Star Wars one day, but you are not getting me into the Lord of the Rings. That is where I draw the line. OK, fine. All right, so we go into the conference room, and all the kids are in there and they're eating candy. And this is when Michael tells them that he used to be the star, calls himself the star of a TV show called, Thundle Bundle.
我是说，我有一天可能会看《星球大战》，但你别想让我看《指环王》。那是我的底线。好的，好吧。好吧，我们进入会议室，所有的孩子都在那里吃糖果。这时迈克尔告诉他们，他曾经是明星，称自己是名为《Fundle Bundle》的电视节目的明星。
Here's my question for you. Cause as I watched this, I kept thinking about this. Is just Michael's memory of this just through rose colored glasses? He doesn't really remember what it was like. He's recreated sort of, he's rewritten history, if you will, right? That he was the star and it was a great thing. Yes. I mean, I think that's pretty common.
这是我给你的问题。因为当我看着这一幕时，我一直在想这个。迈克尔对这件事的记忆只是戴着玫瑰色眼镜吗？他不记得当时是什么样了。他重塑了，或者说，他改写了历史，对吧？他是明星，那是一件伟大的事情。是的。我是说，我觉得这很常见。
I'm thinking of the time for example, that I got to be on the radio reading a poem about the St. Louis Cardinals during the World Series. How old were you? Oh, I was probably... Last year? No, I was like 10. I was 10. Do you think?
我想到那次，例如，我有机会在广播里读一首关于圣路易斯红雀队的诗，在世界大赛期间。你当时多大？哦，我大概……去年？不，我大概10岁。我10岁。你觉得？
Yeah, because it was the 84 World Series, I believe. Okay. So I was 10. Okay. And my memory of it is that I was a radio star. But I'm sure if I heard the audio, it's me like, roses are red, violets are blue, I love the Cardinals and so do you. Right? Like I was probably not the poetry reader you are now.
是啊，因为我相信那是84年的世界大赛。好吧。所以我10岁。好吧。我对它的记忆是我是一个广播明星。但我敢肯定如果我听到录音，那肯定是我在说，“玫瑰是红的，紫罗兰是蓝的，我爱红雀队，你也爱。”对吧？就像我可能不是你现在这样的诗歌朗诵者。
Yes. And who knows what this poem really was. But in my mind, it was such a fabulous poem, it got live on the radio and we all listened. You know. So I think that's what's happened in Michael's brain. He has this childlike nostalgia of what that was. And Fundle Bundle, if it was anything like The Land of Hatchimalatchee, was a big deal in Scranton. And Michael was on it. This is a little bit of a claim to fame.
是的。谁知道这首诗到底是什么。但在我脑海里，那是一首如此美妙的诗，它在广播里直播，我们都听了。你知道。所以我认为迈克尔的大脑里发生了这种情况。他对那段经历有一种孩子气的怀旧。而《Fundle Bundle》，如果它像《Hatchimalatchee之地》一样，那在斯克兰顿可是件大事。迈克尔参与其中。这算是一点点成名。
So he decides, we're going to watch it. He tells Ryan, go get the tape. Go get the tape from my mom's house. And then he goes into this very elaborate explanation. Go to Dixon City, which I looked up. It's about a 14 minute drive. Go to Dixon City. Mom might be by the pool.
所以他决定，我们要看它。他告诉瑞安，去拿磁带。去我妈家拿磁带。然后他开始了一段非常详尽的解释。去迪克森市，我查过了。开车大约14分钟。去迪克森市。妈妈可能在泳池边。
She might be at the pool. At the pool. And so you're going to have to go through the window. Boost yourself up and go to the basement. Can we play this clip? It's at 12 minutes. I just love, Steve delivers it very, very quickly. He just rattles it off as if everything he's saying is totally normal.
她可能在泳池边。在泳池边。所以你得从窗户进去。把自己托上去，去地下室。我们可以播放这段剪辑吗？在12分钟。我只是喜欢，史蒂夫说得非常非常快。他只是脱口而出，好像他说的每一件事都很正常。
And also this is something he's done countless times. Yeah, it's so easy to do. This is how you get in my mom's house. I do it all the time. She's going to be at the pool. Yeah, so you just, you put your, the window will be open though. Yeah. Here it is. I would like you to go to my She's gonna be at the pool. Yeah, so you just, you put your, the window will be open though. Yeah. Here it is.
而且这也是他做过无数次的事情。是啊，这很容易做到。这就是你进入我妈家的方法。我经常这么做。她会在泳池边。是啊，所以你只要，窗户会开着的。是啊。在这里。我希望你去我的……她会在泳池边。是啊，所以你只要，窗户会开着的。是啊。在这里。
I would like you to go to my mother's house in Dixon City, and if she is at the pool, the back kitchen window should be unlocked. I want you to boost yourself up. I want you to go down to the basement. In the basement is a tape labeled Fundle Bundle. I want you to grab it. I want you to get my guitar.
我希望你去我母亲在迪克森市的房子，如果她在泳池边，后厨房的窗户应该是没锁的。我希望你把自己托上去。我希望你去地下室。地下室里有一盘标着《Fundle Bundle》的磁带。我希望你把它拿来。我希望你拿上我的吉他。
Right, okay. I want you to get a tambourine. Do you know how to play the tambourine? I'm already getting the pizzas from Brunetti, so. You know, I can go with him. No, I will go. Okay. I love that. I love that. Oh, get my guitar, which is in his mother's basement.
对，好吧。我希望你拿一个铃鼓。你知道怎么玩铃鼓吗？我已经从布鲁内蒂那里拿披萨了，所以。你知道，我可以和他一起去。不，我会去的。好吧。我很喜欢。我很喜欢。哦，拿上我的吉他，它在他母亲的地下室里。
Yeah. And then, can you play the tambourine? It's, it's, it's all about to happen. It's all about to happen. So, at 12 minutes, 17 seconds, Ryan says he can't go because I'm already getting pizza from Brunetti's. Brunetti's is a real pizza place in Scranton. No jitters, but there is a Brunetti's.
是啊。然后，你能玩铃鼓吗？它，它，它马上就要发生了。它马上就要发生了。所以，在12分17秒，瑞安说他不能去，因为“我已经从布鲁内蒂那里拿披萨了”。布鲁内蒂是斯克兰顿一家真正的披萨店。没有Jitters，但有布鲁内蒂。
There is a Brunetti's, but guys, guess what? What? I went to the Facebook page for Brunetti's. Their pizza is a rectangle. What? Rectangle pizza. Brunetti's. Yeah. Their pizza is a rectangle. What? Rectangle pizza. Brunetti's, scandalous. Not circular pizza.
有布鲁内蒂，但伙计们，猜猜怎么着？什么？我去了布鲁内蒂的Facebook页面。他们的披萨是长方形的。什么？长方形披萨。布鲁内蒂。是啊。他们的披萨是长方形的。什么？长方形披萨。布鲁内蒂，太离谱了。不是圆形披萨。
Like Barone's here. Barone's in Los Angeles, Steve's favorite pizza. Where we would get pizza sometimes on set. For the cast and crew. Square. Rectangle. Oh, rectangle. Yeah, it's made on like a cookie sheet.
就像这里的Barone's。洛杉矶的Barone's，史蒂夫最喜欢的披萨。我们有时会在片场买披萨。给演员和剧组。正方形。长方形。哦，长方形。是啊，它是用饼干烤盘做的。
Mm-hmm. Well, in our episode, we have circular pizzas. To be fair, I did see they tend to sometimes serve circular ones. Well, you heard it here, you guys. You heard it here. Sorry for the circular pizza when it wasn't Brunetti's rectangle pizza. All right, guys. Everybody is in the conference room now
嗯哼。好吧，在我们的剧集里，我们有圆形披萨。公平地说，我确实看到他们有时会供应圆形披萨。好吧，你们在这里听到了。你们在这里听到了。抱歉，当它不是布鲁内蒂的长方形披萨时，却用了圆形披萨。好吧，伙计们。每个人现在都在会议室里
at 12 minutes, 29 seconds. They're eating the circular pizza that should be a rectangle fan catch from Mrs. Cray. What Mrs. Cray? What is the funny dance move that John Krasinski is doing in the background? I don't know, they're just goofing around with the kids. It's just John being John.
在12分29秒。他们正在吃那个应该是长方形的圆形披萨。来自克雷夫人的粉丝捕捉。什么克雷夫人？约翰·卡拉辛斯基在背景里跳的那个有趣的舞蹈动作是什么？我不知道，他们只是在和孩子们胡闹。那只是约翰做约翰自己。
Yeah, he's just playing. That's John. Yeah. If you want to know what John is like, check out 12 minutes, 29 seconds. Yeah, he's just having fun. He is. Are we ready to play this tape from Fundle Bundle? 12 minutes, 51 seconds. The Fundle Bundle tape has arrived.
是啊，他只是在玩。那是约翰。是啊。如果你想知道约翰是什么样，看看12分29秒。是啊，他只是玩得很开心。他是。我们准备好播放《Fundle Bundle》的磁带了吗？12分51秒。《Fundle Bundle》的磁带到了。
We had a lot of fan questions about the Fundle Bundle video and how it was made. So I reached out to Kent Zbornak, our line producer. So he told me that our set designers built the set and that our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, found all of these vintage 1960s outfits for the kids. She was great at that. So good. And probably so excited because all we wore
我们收到了很多关于《Fundle Bundle》视频以及它是如何制作的粉丝提问。所以我联系了我们的制片主任肯特·兹博纳克。他告诉我，我们的布景设计师搭建了布景，我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特为孩子们找到了所有这些1960年代的复古服装。她在这方面很棒。太棒了。而且可能非常兴奋，因为我们穿的
were gray turtlenecks and like beige tops and so she was probably so thrilled to have a project. Here's an interesting bit of trivia about Carrie Bennett. So before our show, Carrie worked on scrubs and she designed some kind of like, I guess quote unquote designer scrubs. She could sew and so she designed her own line of scrubs. That were less boxy, that were more flattering and fitted for both men and women.
全是灰色高领毛衣和米色上衣，所以她可能很高兴能有一个项目。关于凯莉·贝内特有一个有趣的琐事。在我们的剧之前，凯莉在《实习医生风云》工作，她设计了一些类似，我猜是所谓的“设计师刷手服”。她会缝纫，所以她设计了自己的刷手服系列。那些不那么方正，对男女来说都更修身、更显身材。
Different colors and patterns. They were so popular that she actually started a line of scrubs. Yeah, go Carrie. So there you go. So when they shot this footage, they used a cheap video camera instead of one of our regular cameras.
不同的颜色和图案。它们太受欢迎了，以至于她真的开创了一个刷手服系列。是啊，加油凯莉。所以就是这样。所以当他们拍摄这段素材时，他们用了一台廉价摄像机，而不是我们常规的摄像机之一。
And then in post-production, footage they used a cheap video camera instead of one of our regular cameras. And then in post-production, he told me they threw in some additional artifacts. I guess artifacts is a term for lessening the quality of the film image. And so that's how it got that degraded grainy look. Yes. Yeah. We had another fan question from Karen Friar. She said, who was the voice of Edward R. Meow, the puppet
然后在后期制作中，他们用了一台廉价摄像机，而不是我们常规的摄像机之一。然后在后期制作中，他告诉我他们加入了一些额外的伪影。我猜“伪影”是降低电影图像质量的一个术语。所以它才有了那种退化的颗粒感。是的。是啊。我们收到了另一个来自凯伦·弗莱尔的粉丝提问。她说，爱德华·R·喵的配音是谁，那个木偶
that all the kids are talking to in Fundle Bundle? The voice is Kevin Carlson. He is a puppeteer and voice actor, but here's something very sweet. What? I did not know this. Kensa Borneck, our line producer, used to be a puppeteer. Stop it. Yeah. He worked with Jim Henson. Kent? Kent Zbornak worked with
在《Fundle Bundle》里所有孩子都在和它说话？配音是凯文·卡尔森。他是一位木偶师和配音演员，但这里有一件非常甜蜜的事。什么？我不知道这个。我们的制片主任肯特·兹博纳克曾经是一名木偶师。别说了。是啊。他和吉姆·亨森一起工作过。肯特？肯特·兹博纳克和……一起工作过。
Jim Henson and Sid and Mary Croft, and he wanted to be Edward R. Miao. And they didn't let him? No, he couldn't do it in the end. He didn't have the time. He couldn't leave his job of line producing to be Edward Armiao. So he asked his friend, another professional puppeteer, Kevin Carlson, if he would do it. This is that classic thing that I love, where you look at someone, you think you know them. You're like, I know you, you're very efficient.
吉姆·亨森和西德与玛丽·克罗夫特，他当时想成为爱德华·R·喵。他们没让他演吗？不，他最后没能演成。他没时间。他无法放下制片人的工作去当爱德华·R·喵。所以他问了他的朋友，另一位专业木偶师凯文·卡尔森，问他愿不愿意演。这就是我喜欢的那种经典桥段，你看着某个人，以为你了解他们。你会想，我认识你，你效率很高。
Kent's kind of like this high strung, but like nice and kind, but he's getting stuff done. He's got Excel spreadsheets. Yeah, and I'm like, Kent, I know who you are. And then you're a freaking puppeteer. Puppeteer. What? Yeah, I did not know that blew me away
肯特就像那种神经紧绷，但又很友善、很和蔼的人，而且他办事效率很高。他有Excel电子表格。是的，我就想，肯特，我知道你是谁。结果你竟然是个木偶师。木偶师。什么？是的，我当时不知道，这让我大吃一惊。
when he told me that. I love that. Yeah, I love it. But here's something. What? The little blonde kid that gets interviewed by Edward R. Meow. The first kid?
当他告诉我的时候。我喜欢这个。是的，我喜欢。但这里有个情况。什么？那个被爱德华·R·喵采访的小金发男孩。第一个孩子？
The first kid. Yeah. That's Kent's the born ex by Edward R. Miao. The first kid? The first kid. That's Kent's the born ex son, Alec. That's so cute. He had to audition for the role and he got it. He got it. Yeah, he had to audition. Isn't that cute? That is so cute.
第一个孩子。是的。那是肯特和前妻生的孩子，亚历克。太可爱了。他必须为这个角色试镜，然后他成功了。他成功了。是的，他必须试镜。这不可爱吗？这太可爱了。
Should we talk about Chet Montgomery? We should. Chet, he's like a local celebrity. So my hometown is pretty small in North Texas. And the evening news there is, good evening Texoma, because we're right by the Texas Oklahoma border. And the folks that do the news there, the local anchors, I have been in Wichita Falls with my grandmother or mom.
我们要聊聊切特·蒙哥马利吗？我们应该聊聊。切特，他就像个当地名人。我的家乡在北德克萨斯州，相当小。那里的晚间新闻是“晚安，德克萨斯奥克拉荷马”，因为我们就在德克萨斯州和俄克拉荷马州的边界附近。那里的新闻播报员，当地的主播，我以前和祖母或妈妈在威奇托福尔斯时见过。
We're at the mall, are going to Luby's. They love Luby's. What's Luby's? Luby's is like- Do they sell earrings? No, it's like, my grandparents love to go there for lunch. You get a tray- Oh, it's an eatery. You eat there. Yeah, but you get a tray and you go all the way down.
我们在商场，要去Luby's餐厅。他们很喜欢Luby's。Luby's是什么？Luby's就像是……他们卖耳环吗？不，它就像……我祖父母喜欢去那里吃午饭。你拿个托盘……哦，那是一家餐馆。你在那里吃饭。是的，但你拿个托盘，然后一直往前走。
It's like a buffet. Like a cafeteria style buffet thing? Yes. I'd love that place. Oh, yeah. Like a soup plantation? Kind of, yeah. Luby's, it yeah. Luby's.
就像自助餐。像食堂风格的自助餐吗？是的。我喜欢那个地方。哦，是的。像汤料种植园餐厅（Soup Plantation）那样？差不多吧，是的。Luby's，是的。Luby's。
It was called Luby's. It's in the mall. But I remember going there with my grandparents and we saw the local news guy and they were like, there he is. Oh my God. That's the, he does the evening news. Oh my God. We're so excited.
它叫Luby's。在商场里。但我记得和祖父母去那里，我们看到了当地的新闻播报员，他们说，看，他在那儿。天哪。那是……他负责晚间新闻。天哪。我们太兴奋了。
This kid who's being interviewed, he's Chet Montgomery. We find out he's the weather guy. Yeah. Right? He's played by Demone Roberts. Here is a crazy thing about Demone Roberts. Remember earlier in the talking head when Michael says, I'm Eddie Murphy in Raw, but they're gonna make me be Eddie Murphy in Daddy Daycare?
这个被采访的孩子，他是切特·蒙哥马利。我们发现他是天气预报员。是的。对吧？他由德蒙·罗伯茨饰演。关于德蒙·罗伯茨有一件疯狂的事。还记得早些时候在访谈中，迈克尔说：“我是《Raw》里的艾迪·墨菲，但他们却要让我演《奶爸日托》里的艾迪·墨菲”吗？
Is Demone in Daddy Daycare? Yes. Stop it. Yes. That's amazing. Demone Roberts is also in Daddy Daycare. Fan question from gracemarvel5005 and Chris Wolpert, who played Michael as a kid?
德蒙演了《奶爸日托》吗？是的。别开玩笑了。是的。太神奇了。德蒙·罗伯茨也演了《奶爸日托》。来自gracemarvel5005和克里斯·沃尔珀特的粉丝提问，小时候的迈克尔是谁演的？
This was an actor named Jake Callender. Jake Callender. Jake Callender. He sounds like Chuck Montgomery. He does. Jake Callender with Evening News and Texoma. So when Young Michael is interviewed. Didn't you think young Michael looked like young Sheldon
这是一个叫杰克·卡伦德的演员。杰克·卡伦德。杰克·卡伦德。他听起来像查克·蒙哥马利。确实。杰克·卡伦德和晚间新闻以及德克萨斯奥克拉荷马。所以当小迈克尔被采访时。你不觉得小迈克尔看起来像小谢尔顿吗？
a little bit? Oh yeah, I can give you that. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Looks a little bit. Little bit. Okay, so he's interviewed. He's interviewed and he's asked what he wants to be when he grows up.
有一点点？哦，是的，我承认。对吧？是的。是的。看起来有点像。一点点。好吧，所以他被采访了。他被采访，被问到长大后想做什么。
We should also remind you guys, he's in a full suit and tie. Yeah. He's a little kid. Yeah. And he says, I want to be married and have 100 kids so I can have 100 friends and no one can say no to being my friend. Is this when you cried? This is when I had to turn off the episode. It hit me so hard. I don't know why, this idea of just this little kid longing for friends and... Longing for acceptance, but we're getting a real window into his life. Listen. It was just, it was almost too much for me. It was almost too much for me, the sentence about Michael's past. And I think because then you go to Steve's reaction and Steve's acting is so good in
我们还应该提醒你们，他穿着全套西装打着领带。是的。他是个小孩子。是的。他说：“我想结婚，生100个孩子，这样我就有100个朋友，没人能拒绝做我的朋友。”这是你哭的时候吗？这是我不得不关掉这一集的时候。它深深地触动了我。我不知道为什么，这个小孩子渴望朋友的想法，以及……渴望被接纳，但我们真正看到了他的生活。听着。这真的，对我来说几乎难以承受。关于迈克尔过去的这句话，对我来说几乎难以承受。我想是因为接下来你看到了史蒂夫的反应，史蒂夫在那一刻的表演太棒了。
that moment. It just like, I don't know. I mean, I remember at the time when we shot that that after the little Michael says that it cuts to a shot of the puppet and the puppet can't speak, then we lost it. The puppet is like a gape, right? His mouth is open. Do you know that the puppet, they linger on the puppet
我不知道。我的意思是，我记得当时我们拍摄的时候，小迈克尔说完那句话后，镜头切到了木偶，木偶说不出话来，然后我们就崩溃了。木偶张着嘴，对吧？他的嘴是张开的。你知道那个木偶吗，他们停留在木偶身上……
with its mouth open in silence, like that the puppet, they linger on the puppet with its mouth open and silence, like what the heck, right? They linger on that puppet for six seconds of silence. I mean, seeing a puppet with its mouth agape being like, what the F just going on? It is funny. It is funny. And when we were shooting this. Six seconds.
嘴巴张开，沉默着，就像……他们停留在木偶身上，嘴巴张开，沉默着，就像“搞什么鬼”，对吧？他们在那个沉默的木偶身上停留了六秒钟。我的意思是，看到一个木偶张着嘴，好像在说“到底发生了什么鬼事？”这很有趣。这很有趣。当我们拍摄这一幕时。六秒钟。
We were dying. Yeah. We were dying at the shot of the puppet. And so when I was getting ready, I think to sit down and watch the scene, all I could remember was how we were crying laughing at this reaction shot of the puppet. But then I just saw this whole other side of how not funny that was. Well, we were looking at the puppet. We weren't looking at Steve at that moment.
我们快笑死了。是的。我们被木偶的那个镜头逗得不行。所以当我准备坐下来看这一幕时，我唯一记得的就是我们当时看着这个木偶的反应镜头笑得有多厉害。但后来我看到了这一幕不那么好笑的另一面。好吧，我们当时在看木偶。我们当时没看史蒂夫。
Yeah. So we missed that moment for Michael. We needed to watch it as an episode. Yeah, so- As an audience, yeah. Yeah. I just was anyway. Well, the kids start peppering Michael with questions, right? Yeah. They're saying, well, did you get married? Do you have kids? Do you have a girlfriend? And then the little girl says, I guess you didn't get to be
是的。所以我们错过了迈克尔的那一刻。我们需要以观众的身份看这一集。是的，所以……作为观众，是的。是的。我只是……总之。好吧，孩子们开始用问题轰炸迈克尔，对吧？是的。他们说，好吧，你结婚了吗？你有孩子吗？你有女朋友吗？然后那个小女孩说，我想你没能成为……
what you wanted to be. And it is soul crushing. And I was watching this with Isabelle, who's 11, and she turned to me and she goes, Mom, were there just times when you were doing this show that you were like, I am so uncomfortable? She was like, this is really uncomfortable. I mean, she thought it was funny, you know, but she was like, that is awkward. And I was like, yeah, oh yeah,
你想成为的人。这太令人心碎了。我和11岁的伊莎贝尔一起看这一集，她转过头对我说：“妈妈，你在拍这部剧的时候，有没有觉得特别尴尬的时候？”她说：“这真的很尴尬。”我的意思是，她觉得这很有趣，你知道，但她说：“那太尴尬了。”我说：“是的，哦，是的。”
there are a lot of cringey moments on this show, which make it all work in balance. But just the fact that she picked up on that at her age of like what an awkward moment this was. Oh man. Well, Michael is so gutted, he just. He locks himself in his office. He won't come out.
这部剧里有很多让人尴尬的时刻，这让一切保持了平衡。但她在这个年纪就能看出这是一个多么尴尬的时刻，这真是……天哪。好吧，迈克尔太难过了，他把自己锁在办公室里。他不肯出来。
And the reaction shots of all of us are great. We're all really sad for him. Sad, a little embarrassed, all of it. So Pam's talking to Jim. We got a lot of mail about this little scene. Pam's talking to Jim. She's saying, Michael won't come out of his office. He won't answer his phone.
我们所有人的反应镜头都很棒。我们都为他感到难过。难过，有点尴尬，各种情绪都有。所以帕姆在和吉姆说话。我们收到了很多关于这个小场景的邮件。帕姆在和吉姆说话。她说，迈克尔不肯出办公室。他不接电话。
Over her shoulder, Roy is wrestling with Meredith's son. He's so happy. Roy and the jerk kid are having the best time. We had a lot of questions about what this scene was supposed to mean because Pam seems a little bit embarrassed or ashamed that Roy and this kid are getting along. They're like, what did this mean? Well, I think, I don't know. What was your interpretation here? Here is my take on it. Okay.
在她的肩膀后面，罗伊正在和梅雷迪斯的儿子摔跤。他太开心了。罗伊和那个混蛋孩子玩得最开心。我们收到了很多关于这个场景意味着什么的问题，因为帕姆似乎对罗伊和这个孩子相处得很好感到有点尴尬或羞愧。他们问，这是什么意思？好吧，我想，我不知道。你在这里的解读是什么？这是我的看法。好吧。
Because you have Roy, this big guy, right? And he's kind of fratty. He's kind of like a frat guy. And he is with the kid that's the asshole. Right. And they're having the time of their lives. They're in there. There's other people around them.
因为你有罗伊，这个大块头，对吧？他有点像个兄弟会成员。他有点像个兄弟会的人。他和那个混蛋孩子在一起。对。他们玩得非常开心。他们在那里。周围还有其他人。
They're not even caring about other people's personal space. They're wrestling in this room. And Roy's got him in a headlock, and he's like, I love this kid. And I think Pam had a flash of what her life would be like with Roy, with children, what their kids would be like. She is going to have a kid that's like, mom, pull my finger, fart, dad laugh. And Pam was like, oh God, oh no,
他们甚至不在乎别人的个人空间。他们在房间里摔跤。罗伊锁住了他的头，他说，我喜欢这孩子。我想帕姆闪过一个念头，想到她和罗伊的生活会是什么样，有了孩子，他们的孩子会是什么样。她会有一个孩子，像那种“妈妈，拉我的手指，放个屁，爸爸笑”的孩子。帕姆当时想，哦天哪，哦不，
I'm gonna be outnumbered in my own house by like the Roy kids. Yeah, I think it's definitely there to show a contrast to the way Jim bonds with a kid over books and reading, as opposed to just roughhousing. But I have to say, when I saw that, I thought, yes, that's what this kid needs, actually. He needs a father figure in his life. He needs someone to wrestle with him because that is an important part of parenting.
我在自己家里会被罗伊式的孩子淹没。是的，我认为这绝对是为了展示吉姆通过书本和阅读与孩子建立联系的方式，与单纯的打闹形成对比。但我必须说，当我看到那一幕时，我想，是的，这正是这个孩子需要的，实际上。他需要生活中的父亲形象。他需要有人和他摔跤，因为那是育儿的重要组成部分。
I didn't think that that was so bad of a thing, right? No, I think it's perfect for Roy. The problem is that's not what Pam wants in a dad. Pam wants more of a gym dad that is gonna do a silly dance and talk about books and probably wrestle a little bit too. But I think Roy is just a little brutish. It's absolutely what Meredith's son needs. I mean, he needs a big guy to like grab him and be like, Hey, yeah, you know, pay attention. But I just think it's just
我不觉得那是一件很糟糕的事情，对吧？不，我觉得这对罗伊来说很完美。问题是，那不是帕姆想要的爸爸。帕姆想要更多像吉姆那样的爸爸，会跳傻舞，谈论书本，可能也会稍微摔跤一下。但我认为罗伊只是有点粗鲁。这绝对是梅雷迪斯的儿子所需要的。我的意思是，他需要一个大块头来抓住他，说：“嘿，是的，你知道，注意点。”但我只是觉得……
that moment that shows that Jim and Pam are just, you know, you meet people, we all like dated people. And there's some people, you know, instinctively that you're going to parent the same with. Yeah. And I think Pam and Jim are gonna parent the same. Yes. Yeah, I think that's good. That's good, that's good analysis. I like that. Well, next up we go to the copier with Dwight and we're gonna see how Dwight might parent Jake. Well, again, Dwight and Angela,
那一刻显示出吉姆和帕姆只是……你知道，你遇到过一些人，我们都和别人约会过。有些人在直觉上你就知道你们会以同样的方式养育孩子。是的。我认为帕姆和吉姆会以同样的方式养育孩子。是的。是的，我认为这很好。这很好，很好的分析。我喜欢这个。好吧，接下来我们去复印机那里找德怀特，我们要看看德怀特可能会怎么养育杰克。好吧，再说一次，德怀特和安吉拉，
Angela has told him he needs to be tougher with the kids. Basically that's her subtext because that's what she would expect, right? That's what she had growing up and she expects him to be that way. Yeah. So she's egging him on. She is glaring at him like, shut the kid up. Jake tells Dwight that he's ugly. Yeah. And then Dwight is horrible. I'm sorry. At my plotting, he's horrible. Can I get my mini soap box out again? Because I did not care for this.
安吉拉告诉他，他需要对孩子们更强硬。基本上那是她的潜台词，因为那是她所期望的，对吧？那是她成长过程中所经历的，她期望他也是那样。是的。所以她在怂恿他。她怒视着他，好像在说：“让那孩子闭嘴。”杰克告诉德怀特他很丑。是的。然后德怀特表现得很糟糕。抱歉。在我的策划中，他很糟糕。我能再次拿出我的迷你肥皂箱吗？因为我不喜欢这样。
No, it wasn't good. It bumped me. I didn't like that Dwight told a child, like that Dwight insulted a child the way he did. I didn't, I think we're meant as an audience to be like, yeah, you give it to the jerk kid. But I just, that, I didn't like it. I don't think we're meant to do that.
不，这不好。这让我很不舒服。我不喜欢德怀特那样侮辱一个孩子。我不觉得，我想我们作为观众应该觉得，是的，给那个混蛋孩子一点教训。但我只是……我不喜欢那样。我不认为我们应该那样做。
You don't think? I don't think so. I think like, there's part of you that's like glad that this kid is like at least putting his place a little bit, although done completely inappropriately. But I think what I took away from it is like, Dwight, Dwight is a kid. You have two, these are two kids in one conversation. I mean, Isabel watched it with me and she was like, oh mom, Dwight. And I said,
你不觉得吗？我不这么认为。我觉得，你内心的一部分会觉得很高兴这个孩子至少被稍微教训了一下，尽管方式完全不合适。但我从中学到的是，德怀特，德怀特是个孩子。这是一次对话中的两个孩子。我的意思是，伊莎贝尔和我一起看，她说：“哦，妈妈，德怀特。”我说，
I know he's just a kid. Well, it all just made me super sad for Jake. Oh, well, Jake, Jake is doomed. That's what I felt like. He's married his kid and he's doomed. At 15 minutes, 39 seconds, Pam strikes out again. Oh boy. Yeah, Melissa comes over. She's like, you know, I've spent some time with your mom. She's so nice. And Melissa's like, that lady is not my mother. Like, you mean Terry?
我知道他只是个孩子。好吧，这一切都让我为杰克感到非常难过。哦，好吧，杰克，杰克注定要倒霉了。这就是我的感觉。他娶了那个孩子，他注定要倒霉。在15分39秒，帕姆再次出局。哦，天哪。是的，梅丽莎过来了。她说，你知道，我和你妈妈待了一会儿。她真好。梅丽莎说，那个女人不是我妈妈。你是说特里？
That's my stepmom. Yeah. So now she's like, oh for two, right? Oh yeah. Pam's not doing great until Jake comes over. Jake's probably a little wounded by this time. I think he's a little softer around the edges now. Maybe so.
那是我的继母。是的。所以现在她就像，哦，两次都错了，对吧？哦，是的。帕姆表现得不太好，直到杰克过来。杰克这时候可能有点受伤了。我觉得他现在稍微温和了一点。也许吧。
And she's like, do you wanna shred some stuff? Your shredder. My shredder, 17 minutes, 50 seconds, everyone. Your shredder that you said we never use and people were like, oh, I'm getting to my keyboard. Yes, boy, we got a lot of mail after I said that early on. Yes, Pam does use her shredder. With Jake.
她说，你想碎掉一些东西吗？你的碎纸机。我的碎纸机，17分50秒，各位。你的碎纸机，你说我们从不使用，人们说，哦，我要去我的键盘上了。是的，伙计，我早些时候那样说之后，我们收到了很多邮件。是的，帕姆确实用了她的碎纸机。和杰克一起。
By the way, I want to say that original shredder did not work. It was inoperable. And I can't remember now if they had to bring in some other shredder. I think there's a reason why there's not a great shot of it is because it doesn't technically match the giant shredder that's always been there. I will say also in our early years on set, I know we were on a tight budget, right? We were the show that was almost going to get canceled. We were like, it was sort of shoestring budget. And a lot of our appliances in the office, if you
顺便说一句，我想说最初那个碎纸机不能用。它是坏的。我不记得他们是否不得不带入另一个碎纸机。我想有一个原因，为什么没有它的好镜头，是因为它在技术上与一直放在那里的巨大碎纸机不匹配。我还想说，在我们拍摄的早期，我知道我们的预算很紧，对吧？我们是差点被取消的节目。我们就像，预算非常紧张。我们办公室里的很多电器，如果你……
look really closely, are old used appliances that they would take from like a prop warehouse or other shows. Oh, the copier didn't work at first. And then they wrote that someone uses the copier and they're like, whoa, hold up. That doesn't work. We need a copier. We were just, I mean, that was just decoration.
仔细看，都是从道具仓库或其他节目中拿来的旧电器。哦，复印机起初不能用。然后他们写道有人使用复印机，他们说，哇，等等。那不能用。我们需要一台复印机。我们只是……我的意思是，那只是装饰。
It's just a prop. We're planning on using that. And that shredder looked like something from the Dharma initiative. It looked really old. Well, you remember that copier used to often not work right. Do you remember that? We were always fixing that copier.
它只是个道具。我们打算用那个。那个碎纸机看起来像达摩计划里的东西。它看起来真的很旧。好吧，你记得那台复印机经常不能正常工作。你记得吗？我们一直在修理那台复印机。
All the time. But then when I worked in offices, we were always fixing our copiers. So maybe it worked just as it was meant to work. Or as good as any copier I've ever used. All right. All right, so now Toby goes into Michael's office and he's returning the toys that Sasha took. And Toby asked Michael if he's okay. And Michael says,
一直都在修。但后来我在办公室工作时，我们也一直在修理复印机。所以也许它就像它应该工作的那样工作。或者和我用过的任何复印机一样好。好吧。好吧，现在托比走进迈克尔的办公室，他归还了萨莎拿走的玩具。托比问迈克尔他是否还好。迈克尔说，
well, you have to ask me that because you're head of HR. And Toby's like, well, it's true. It's true. But how are you? And then they end up having a heart to heart. A sweet heart to heart. Michael and Toby. I know.
好吧，你必须问我，因为你是人力资源部主管。托比说，好吧，这是真的。这是真的。但你还好吗？然后他们最终进行了一次交心。一次甜蜜的交心。迈克尔和托比。我知道。
But of course, then Michael asks if Sasha has a godfather. And Toby's like, she does. Toby actually cuts him off. So he's like, hey, does Sasha have a godfather because no, he does. He does. She does. Yeah. But Michael decides he's feeling a little better.
但当然，迈克尔问萨莎是否有教父。托比说，她有。托比实际上打断了他。所以他说，嘿，萨莎有教父吗？因为不，他有。他有。她有。是的。但迈克尔决定他感觉好多了。
He's going to sign up for an online dating service. He's going to get out there. He is. He's going to try to make little Michael Scott's dream come true. Let's get married and have his 100 kids. And he wants the ladies out there to know how serious he is about having a family and his love of children. So he makes his username, little kid lover.
他要注册一个在线约会服务。他要走出去。他会的。他要努力让小迈克尔·斯科特的梦想成真。让我们结婚，生100个孩子。他想让外面的女士们知道他对于拥有家庭和对孩子的热爱是多么认真。所以他把用户名设为“小孩子爱好者”。
Yeah, he's gonna do it. Oh boy. All right, so now, huge bombshell. Abby is leaving with Kevin and she wants to invite Jim over for dinner. Very sweet. He can't, he has plans. He has plans.
是的，他要这么做。哦，天哪。好吧，现在，巨大的重磅炸弹。艾比要和凯文一起离开，她想邀请吉姆去吃晚饭。非常甜蜜。他不能，他有计划。他有计划。
What plans, Kevin says? You never has plans. What plans, Kevin says? You never have plans. Guess what, guys? Jim has a date. Jim has a date. With who? Is this maybe Brenda? Is Brenda back?
什么计划，凯文说？你从来没有计划。什么计划，凯文说？你从来没有计划。猜猜怎么着，伙计们？吉姆有约会。吉姆有约会。和谁？这可能是布伦达吗？布伦达回来了吗？
Fan question, Laura Dini would like to know. Who is Jim going on a date with? Don't know. Brenda? Is he lying? No, he has a date. No, he has a date. I think he does. No, he for sure has a date. Yeah. So then we get to the last scene of the episode. This is the second time I cried in this episode.
粉丝提问，劳拉·迪尼想知道。吉姆要和谁约会？不知道。布伦达？他在撒谎吗？不，他有约会。不，他有约会。我想他有。不，他肯定有约会。是的。所以我们到了这一集的最后一个场景。这是我在这一集中第二次哭。
When they were singing? Yeah. Jenna. Dwight is playing guitar. I get the first one. Why did you cry in this one? I don't know. This song really gets to me. Teach Your Children, Michael is singing. Crosby, Stills and Nash. Yeah. And Young, I guess. I love how, I love how Steve does this. He went for it.
当他们唱歌的时候？是的。珍娜。德怀特在弹吉他。我理解第一个。你为什么在这个场景里哭？我不知道。这首歌真的触动了我。《教导你的孩子》，迈克尔在唱。克罗斯比、斯蒂尔斯和纳什。是的。还有杨，我想。我喜欢史蒂夫这样做的方式。他全力以赴了。
He went for it. His very weird harmony. Falsetto. Yeah. Yeah. And during this scene, Jim and Pam have a little banter. Hi falsetto. Yeah. Yeah. And during this scene Jim and Pam have a little banter. A little banter. This was a real kick in the nuts for Pam. This was a tough one. Jim says, why does he have a guitar if he never plays it? They're doing their thing
他全力以赴了。他非常奇怪的和声。假声。是的。是的。在这个场景中，吉姆和帕姆有一些调侃。嗨，假声。是的。是的。在这个场景中，吉姆和帕姆有一些调侃。一点调侃。这对帕姆来说真是个打击。这是一个艰难的时刻。吉姆说，为什么他有吉他却从不弹？他们在做他们的事……
where they kind of flirt and chitty chat in the corner. Exactly. They're commenting on what's happening. But then they kind of giggle. Then Pam looks away and she turns back and she's like, well, my theory is he's gone. Jim's gone. Yeah. And then your little adjustment after you realize you were talking to no one and that he's gone is so great. Cause you kind of feel her like, oh, okay.
他们在角落里调情和聊天。没错。他们在评论正在发生的事情。但后来他们咯咯笑了。然后帕姆看向别处，她转过身说，好吧，我的理论是他走了。吉姆走了。是的。然后你在意识到你在和空气说话，而他已经走了之后，你的小调整太棒了。因为你感觉到她，哦，好吧。
So at 19 minutes, one second, we sort of start this montage, right? Jim is leaving. Yeah. And you see this really sweet thing with Michael and Sasha. He's kind of helping, I think, get her in Toby's car. And then you end with this Dwight talking head. Yeah.
所以在19分01秒，我们开始了这个蒙太奇，对吧？吉姆要走了。是的。你看到了迈克尔和萨莎之间非常甜蜜的事情。我想他是在帮她上托比的车。然后你以德怀特的访谈结束。是的。
It's so good. What? OK, I have a Yeah. It's so good. What? OK. I have a question. Yeah. Where is that photo from? I found out. Good.
太棒了。什么？好的，我有一个……是的。太棒了。什么？好的。我有一个问题。是的。那张照片是从哪里来的？我发现了。太好了。
I was hoping you would. Yeah. So during this talking head, Dwight is kind of explaining the value of children in the Shrut ancestry. And there is this photo, this black and white photo of a family, seemingly kind of impoverished family.
我希望你能发现。是的。所以在这次访谈中，德怀特在解释孩子在施鲁特祖先中的价值。有一张照片，这张黑白照片，一个家庭，看起来似乎是一个贫困家庭。
Impoverished family. Well, Dwight says that they would have a lot of children so they could work the fields, which you know, is not a real stretch because my mom grew up in rural Texas on a farm and she had their 12 siblings. They all worked the farm. I think that was a thing. Yeah, that was a thing. Yeah. That was a thing. Yeah.
贫困家庭。好吧，德怀特说他们会生很多孩子，这样他们就可以在田里干活，你知道，这并不牵强，因为我妈妈是在德克萨斯州的农村农场长大的，她有12个兄弟姐妹。他们都在农场干活。我想那是一回事。是的，那是一回事。是的。那是一回事。是的。
Life on the prairie. Little house on the prairie. We learned that from Little House on the Prairie. Not really, but. That family had a lot of kids and they all worked that field and farm. They had like four. I think they had more than that. Five.
草原上的生活。《草原小屋》。我们从《草原小屋》中学到了这一点。不是真的，但是。那个家庭有很多孩子，他们都在田里和农场干活。他们有四个。我想他们不止那些。五个。
I feel like it was upwards of seven. What? Mara, Mara, Mary, half pint. Yeah, the baby who I think died on Christmas Eve, a fever. There were some boys, one boy. Maybe there were only four or five. I don't know, they all worked the farm though. Anyway, Dwight also says that they sometimes
我觉得有七个以上。什么？玛拉，玛拉，玛丽，半品脱。是的，那个我想在平安夜死于发烧的婴儿。有几个男孩，一个男孩。也许只有四个或五个。我不知道，但他们都在农场干活。总之，德怀特还说他们有时……
ate the weakest person in times of real hardship. And then he was like, but not a kid. We didn't eat the babies. But the way he says it means like maybe sometimes they did. No, he said, I'm kidding. We never ate the children. It never came to that. Right.
在真正的困难时期吃掉最弱的人。然后他说，但不是孩子。我们没吃婴儿。但他说话的方式意味着也许有时他们确实吃了。不，他说，我在开玩笑。我们从不吃孩子。从来没到那一步。对吧。
But if it did. They were, yeah. All right, well, at 20 minutes, 17 seconds, there is a shot of this photo. And in the Booze Cruise podcast, we mentioned that Rain did bring in a number of photos of his real family. Is this one?
但如果到了那一步。他们是，是的。好吧，在20分17秒，有一个这张照片的镜头。在《游轮》播客中，我们提到雷恩确实带了一些他真实家人的照片。这是其中一张吗？
No, it's not. There was a real photo of his family in the vending machine in the cold open of Booze Cruise, but this was not Rain's real family. Kent told me that they just found it on Getty Images. It's a stock photo. They just licensed it and it became the lore of Dwight's family right there.
不，不是。在《游轮》的冷开场中，自动售货机里确实有他家人的真实照片，但这并不是雷恩真实的家人。肯特告诉我，他们只是在Getty Images上找到的。这是一张库存照片。他们只是获得了许可，它就成了德怀特家族的传说。
Just a picture. There you go. It's somebody's family. It's someone's family. Maybe someone will write in and say, Hey, those are my ancestors. Those are my ancestors. A Getty image photographer came to a reunion in 1814.
只是一张照片。给你。那是某人的家庭。那是某人的家庭。也许有人会写信说，嘿，那是我的祖先。那是我的祖先。一位Getty Images摄影师在1814年参加了一次聚会。
Yeah. Anyway. All right, well, there you go. That's our episode. All right, you guys, that's Take Your Daughter to Work Day. If you have any questions, if we left anything out, write us in and we will see you next week. We will, I think, for Michael's
是的。总之。好吧，给你。这就是我们的剧集。好吧，伙计们，这就是“带女儿上班日”。如果你有任何问题，如果我们漏掉了什么，写信给我们，我们下周见。我想我们会讨论迈克尔的……
birthday. Michael's birthday! Yeah, the ice skating rink. Oh, I have good photos from that one. I have good stories. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer
生日。迈克尔的生日！是的，溜冰场。哦，我那里有很好的照片。我有很好的故事。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人……
is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和利亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。